what's up programmers in scriptures this
is right here and in this course you are
going to learn how to build a native
android application using Kotlin jetpack
libraries and a little bit of help from
firebase now before we jump into the
Android stuff please be aware that the
audio quality does improve after the
first section of this course be sure to
check out the timestamps in the
description box and also check out the
pend comment down below for links to
more awesome educational content so
that's it hopefully you enjoyed the
tutorial what's up everybody
this is ryan here and you are watching
my jetpack notes mvvm android Kotlin
tutorial so in this video what I'm going
to do is I'm going to demonstrate the
application that we'll be building
throughout this tutorial series or
building in increments and then we'll
also have a look at basically a huge
list of topics that we'll be covering so
that you know what to expect in this
tutorial series so before we get to
those finer details let's do a quick
demo of the application jetpack notes
has three features or primary user
interface screens we're looking at the
note list feature currently and as you
can see we don't have any notes so it's
kind of in an idle State so note let's
display displays all the notes which are
currently stored either in the local
room database or the remote fire store
database and the decision of where to
save or retrieve notes is based on
whether the user is logged in or not and
that's actually a concern which is
handled in the backend of the
application so from this screen we can
also create a new note so I'm just going
to hit the plus button and we'll just
create new oops
I can't type new note like so and then
I'll hit the check mark button this is
also where you can delete notes and as
you can see we have the new note here
next thing I'm going to do is I'm going
to hit the key icon which will open the
login feature and as you can see we are
currently signed in so what I'm going to
do is I'm going to sign out okay and
then I'm going to head back to the note
list feature by hitting the back button
and as you can see we have a totally
different note currently present for
because that is what's coming from the
local room database so I'm just going to
hit that hit the delete button and as
you can see that's cleared that out and
then we'll just log back in again
sometimes it takes a moment there we go
there we are and boom new note so that's
a quick demo of the application and this
is what we will be building in this
tutorial so in order to follow along
with the tutorial you're going to need
to visit the repository link down in the
description box below
and you'll need to either clone or
download the code so that you can follow
along properly what I'll do is in each
lesson I'll sort of go through with you
I'll give you specific instructions on
how to create a starting point so we're
all on the same page and then we'll
carry on from there
this tutorial will cover both front end
middle and back-end topics for Android
development for front-end
we'll look at constraint layout simple
Android animations using animation lists
using vector graphics which will
basically allow you to have cool
graphics and animations which will scale
with whatever resolution or screen size
you're working with I'll show you how to
build a recycler view which happens to
be the first thing I ever taught people
to do on YouTube and then we will look
at implementing the navigation library
from jetpack view models from Android
architecture components fragments and
I'll do in the next video of a big talk
about model view viewmodel
front-end architecture pattern
we're back in topics I'll teach you
about using firebase off and Google
sign-in provider for a quick and easy
user management we'll look at using room
and fire store for local and remote data
storage respectively I'll teach you how
to hide these things behind a repository
so that the front-end doesn't know or
care where the notes come from and we'll
also learn about simple dependency
injection using Android view model and
view model providers to get everything
nice and wired together and finally
we'll talk about how to wire the
end-to-end application together using
Kotlin co-routines
and let me tell you I think you're
really going to enjoy that part
and in this video I'm going to be giving
you an overview and kind of an
examination of the pros and cons of
using the model view viewmodel
architecture which is the architecture
that we'll be using in this particular
tutorial series we'll also have a quick
look at the packages and files for the
demo application just so you understand
what's going on there now before we look
at this pattern in detail I'd like to
address what I consider to be a few
misconceptions about not just model view
viewmodel
but software architecture front-end GUI
patterns in general so I'm going to
assume that most of you have heard about
all kinds of different three layer
architecture there's Model View
controller Model View presenter model
view viewmodel which Google seems to be
putting all of their weight behind or
sorry the Android team rather and then
we have other options like Viper or
there's Model View intent by Hannes
Dorfman and I'm sure what most of you
are wondering is would someone please
just tell me which one of these is the
best architecture well I'm going to try
and burst your bubble right now because
in my personal opinion the answer and
this is opinion is fairly widely shared
among senior developers is that the
project requirements at hand will
dictate the best architecture for you so
one of the things that I've noticed over
the years of trying several different
approaches different patterns is that
they work good in some situations and
they can be counterproductive in others
now it's better to follow an
architecture which doesn't really work
super well for your problem requirements
then no architecture at all but what I'm
trying to say here is that over time
when you know things about all these
different patterns you start to see ok
well this particular feature of this
pattern is useful in situation a but
it's kind of a problem in situation B so
what I would like to do is basically
explain in this video that model view
viewmodel is not an exception to that
rule it is not necessarily the best
architecture for all situations even on
the Android platform but it does have
some benefits and some deficits so what
I would like to do is basically give you
an idea of what those benefits
and deficits are and yeah we'll get into
that in a moment but before we talk
about that I'm going to try to give you
like a general overview of the
architecture use the whiteboard example
ok so what we're going to do now is
we're going to talk a little about the
model view viewmodel front end graphical
user interface pattern before I jump
into this one thing to note is that
unfortunately developers do not always
consistently build these things the same
way so what I'm going to explain to you
is a generalization this is my
interpretation of the model view
viewmodel
architecture but like I say you're going
to find different variations of this and
the most important thing for you to know
is that different variations will work
better in different situations so what
exactly happens how does it work so the
first and most important thing that the
defining characteristic of model view
viewmodel
in my opinion is that essentially we
have this thing called a view model in
the middle which encapsulate the both
the behavior and the state of the front
end of the view both the behavior in the
state so state being the data and the
behavior being what do we do when some
event happens kind of deal so the thing
that's unique about model view viewmodel
is that the this thing in the middle of
the view model you're not allowed to
have this view model actually directly
tell the view what to do I'm not allowed
to draw a line from here to here which
would be a dependency so if you're doing
Model View presenter you are allowed to
do that in model view viewmodel you're
not based on my interpretation instead
what happens is we basically have to
have two dependencies two different
channels from the view to the view model
this is typically how we like to set it
up so one channel is just synchronous
and this would be the kind of thing
where let's say for example if we're
coding for Android or whatever
the user hits a button and then the view
can just if you know just do a
synchronous call just a function call to
the view model hey this button was
clicked so that's one of the ways it can
communicate with the view model the
other way and this is how it actually
gets the data out of the view model and
this is confusing for some people is
that you see this eyeball thing here
this is my representation of what's
known as the observer pattern so you
could use data binding what I like to do
is I like to use basically a producer
consumer consumer relationship or the
observer pattern it's called between the
view model between the view and the view
model so basically what I'm saying here
is at the start at some point the view
model will ask for observables so it's
going to ask for something from the view
and this thing that it gets sorry it's
gonna ask for something in the out of
the view model and when it gets that
object that observable object I want you
to think of that observable object as
like a pipe that data pops out of at on
indeterminate time whenever the data
pops out of the pipe
whenever the v-model asks the model the
back end for some data it's going to
then publish that data and if the view
is listening then the view is going to
grab that data that pops out of the the
observable pipe and then it's going to
render that on the screen so that's
basically how model view viewmodel
generally speaking works so one of the
things to keep in mind about this is
that the the benefit of model view view
model is can also be the deficit so one
of the main benefits of it is we can
have a many to one ratio of views to
view models and that's because the view
model does not depend on any view
specifically the cost of that is that
you lose fine-grained control over what
the view does so naturally in many cases
you're going to have to actually have
more logic in your view because the view
is going to have to be able to
you interpret what's coming in from the
observable streams so there's different
ways to solve that and the logic isn't
necessarily going to be super
complicated but this is one of the
things you want to think about when
you're working with model view viewmodel
in particular so now that I've given you
like a general overview of the pattern I
just wanted to get a little bit more
specific about the things I am fond of
and not so fond of in this particular
architecture with the hopes that it can
help you inform your decision about
whether you think it's a good idea to
use it or not so the most important
thing just to start with the cons here
in this particular architecture is that
the synchronization between the view and
the view model presents a problem of
separation of concerns if you're not
sure what separation of concerns is I've
written an article and I'll link it down
in the description box below and it will
basically explain my perspective on
separation of concerns but I actually do
consider it to be probably the most
important principle to observe in
software architecture anyways the reason
why the synchronization logic can be
awkward and there are ways around it is
because we don't have that fine-grained
control over the view so this means we
have basically two options and these are
kind of what I would consider to be
subsets of model view viewmodel
so option number one is to basically
fill the view with all bunch of logic to
interpret the data which the view model
publishes to it so this approach will
allow you to have very reusable view
models but it's going to basically make
it so that you fill your fragments or
whatever view class you're using with a
whole bunch of logic when you fill
something with a whole bunch of logic
that's really the time when you really
need to be careful about testing now I
personally don't like to test UI classes
instead I use humble object or passive
view which basically makes those classes
generally speaking one-liners and it
makes them simple enough that they don't
even directly
to be tested if you don't take that
approach and you want to fill your
fragments or views with lots of logic
you will need to probably use espresso
or Robo Electric to make sure that
you're testing everything adequately so
one of the ways around this and this is
the key problem is the presentation
logic is awkwardly distributed between
the view and the view model one of the
ways around this is to actually make it
so that your view model knows a fair
amount about the particular view that
it's working with so what I mean by that
is it's not that it has a direct
dependency but you can fill your view
model with all kinds of in this tutorial
it'd be like live data observables you
can fill it with a whole bunch of these
observable fields which will dictate for
example should this textbox be
highlighted or this that and the other
basically details about the view without
actually having a direct dependency so
this will allow you to basically pull a
lot of logic out of back out of the view
and into the view model and that's going
to make for a much easier to test view
the caveat to doing this is that if you
have all kinds of details about a
specific view in a view model even if
there's no direct dependency you are
still tightly coupling that view model
to that particular view so you lose the
reusability of the view model if you
take that approach in exchange for not
having to have a whole bunch of logic in
your fragments so with those
considerations in mind which aren't
necessarily application breaking but as
you can see there's not actually a truly
specific model view viewmodel pattern
here there's actually some variations in
it and this is something that I've even
heard the Android team admit when they
were looking into this particular
pattern so as you can see we've kind of
got these different approaches to it and
they're going to have different benefits
so if your user interfaces are like
super simple then you're probably going
to be able to get away with having
fairly decoupled unspecific view models
and that's kind of one of the main
benefits of this particular approach is
that if you don't tightly couple
your view models to predict particular
views great English here then you can
promote the reusability of those view
models side benefits is of course you
are applying some kind of separation of
concerns by separating these things out
so you're going to get some benefits to
testing and modularity as well and one
important feature which this is
something that's specific to androids
particular tools or Android architecture
components and and jetpack and that but
one of the biggest benefits for this
particular approach on the Android
platform is that concurrency and life
cycle really is a breeze when you apply
this particular architecture and you use
their components so the final more
detailed point I'd like to make on this
particular architecture is that if you
confine yourself to just having model
view viewmodel then you are definitely
well I would say definitely but probably
going to run into problems where you
have this awkward separation between the
synchronization logic of the view model
and the view and you have to kind of
pick one path or the other reusability
or not filling your views full of logic
there's actually another solution which
you can apply which is actually what I
apply in my production code I don't
confine myself to just using model view
viewmodel
in fact most of my architectures when
you look at them you'll usually see
something which is something along the
lines of like model-view-presenter
view model and the view model has a
different role it's not so much a logic
class as just a front-end session data
container so anyways the point of that
is just to say here for the people
listening this certainly new model view
viewmodel and carry it as far as you
would like but if you get into a
situation where you have this ugly
awkward division of presentation logic
between this the view and the view model
another option is to actually create a
fourth class like a presenter call it
whatever the hell you want I just call
it a logic class
and then you can actually pull out that
logic again decouple it from the view
model and then you can have this sort of
fourth object handle things like click
events it's going to simplify your view
models and I would kind of suggest that
as you start to build more and more
complicated applications if you're
building simple applications though
usually you can get away just fine with
just having the view view model in the
model so the last thing I'll be doing in
this video is giving you an overview of
the package structure of this particular
application so the repository is at
jetpack notes mvvm Kotlin under bracket
Cove link in the description box down
below and what we'll do is we'll just
open up the app module here let me just
zoom in a little and I just wanted to
talk about what's within the main
package here so we've got four primary
packages or directories so within common
you're going to find classes which are
shared across different parts of the
application so that's why we have this
common module here so this is where I
like to put things like for example base
classes so we have a base view model
which is like an abstract class which
shares some code across a set of
different view models constants and a
lot of extensions so there's a lot of
ugly kind of data mapping stuff and this
is something that basically converts
from a firebase task into our XJ or
sorry co-routines not rx Java force of
habit and yeah just all kinds of mappers
and stuff like that so we'll be going
into more detail but I just wanted to
give you a quick glimpse there so that's
common we have the basically two primary
features of the application so we have
the login feature and the note feature
within login you'll of course find the
login activity log in event log in view
and user view model and then in each of
these feature packages you're going to
find a subdirectory called build logic
which will basically contain the
dependency injection and user view model
Factory stuff to create the view models
no dagger to required so everyone can
chill the chill out about
so anyways one important point here is
that I did actually try to do a single
activity approach in this particular
application as per what they suggest in
navigation I was not able to do too
tight coupling to on activity result
which as of making this tutorial is not
supported by the navigation library if
you're watching this in the future it
may be now and that is probably my
biggest criticism of the navigation
library at this point is that it did not
support on activity result which is
problematic anyways I will be demoing
the navigation library in this tutorial
but I even though I tried to do single
activity I literally couldn't so there's
two activities and three features next
we have the model package so this is
basically going to contain everything
which is related to storage and access
to data
so we're thinking repositories
implementations firebase stuff room
stuff data models that kind of stuff
like I say will go into more detail
later so then we have the note directory
which contains all the different files
necessary for the note detail and the
note list features so as you can see
here it's pretty much what we like to
call packaged by feature approach but
something which isn't doesn't
necessarily fit into a particular
feature I will put that in a common
directory so within the note package you
see we have the note detail and note
lists subdirectories and these this will
contain the views and view events and
build logic for this particular UI
screen and I chose to group them
together because they both work on the
same concept conceptual note object and
then we of course have the view models
and factories and stuff like that for
these different views so that's it for
this particular video hopefully you
learn not just about model view
viewmodel but a little bit about
software architecture in general and my
goal here isn't to a crap on model view
viewmodel or to say that you shouldn't
use that approach I think you can build
beautiful applications with this
particular pattern
what I wanted to do though is kind of
explained a lot of the beginners out
there who are confused about this
particular point that the big kind of
consideration with this architecture is
that synchronization between the view
and the view model can be a little bit
awkward there's ways to solve it though
and we'll talk about that as we progress
through the tutorial
so for starters I'm going to show you
how to find free open license images
like the one this animation is based off
of I'm going to show you how to create
scalable vector graphics out of these
PNG s or raster graphics using some free
tools I'm going to show you how to
import those vector graphics into
Android studio so that we can actually
use them in our applications and finally
I'll show you how to create some simple
but effective animations which scale and
it won't require you learning 15
different animation ap is because we all
know there's quite a few different
animation api's on the android platform
so if all of that sounds interesting to
you please do consider hitting the light
but like button down below consider
subscribing and with that let's jump
into some discussion on vector drawables
and graphics versus raster trembles and
graphics now you may be wondering what
exactly is a vector drawable and how is
it different from say like a bitmap PNG
jpg or all those other formats that
you're used to working with
well the key difference is that bitmaps
or PNG or JPEG zahl those sorts of
things which are known as raster
graphics are in essence a collection of
bits bitmap hence which ultimately
represent pixels drawn on the screen so
for example if we wanted to in a raster
graphic type format render a triangle
then ultimately you're going to end up
with something that looks about like
this if you zoom in close enough so we
want to think of like each sort of
segment of some screen or device has a
finite number of pixels and then we
basically say these are the pixels that
we want to draw this is the color and
you end up with something like that so
the problem with these particular
formats which are as I said known as
raster graphics is that they don't scale
well across a variety of different
displays or resolutions one solution to
this is to provide many different
versions of the same images the same
image which have different resolutions
so on really
high-quality device you're going to
provide a much higher resolution icon or
image or something like that while this
kind of works the problem with it is
that you can end up with a situation
where you're bloating you're packaged
applications or taking up a whole bunch
of your users data by downloading a
whole bunch of really large image files
so if possible we kind of try to advise
against having just a huge number of
image files in your apk so as opposed to
having say a finite number of pixels
represented in some kind of collection
format vector drawables take a different
approach so essentially what we're doing
is we're supplying a series of
coordinates and you can add much more
detail than just coordinates but say for
example if we wanted to render a
triangle we would for example give in
this file we would write down a series
of points so for example x1 y1 x2 y2 x3
x3 y3 and then what you would do is you
would instruct the computer to draw say
lines of a particular color between
these points and as you can see the
benefit of doing this is that the actual
work of figuring out the scaling and
resolution and how to render it on a
particular device screen it's done on
the fly and it's independent of finite
set of pixels so that's a big fancy way
of saying it makes it scalable it's
basically like saying hey here's what I
want you to draw and then the computer
basically figures out the mathematics of
doing all the scaling and stuff like
that the end result is that you get
images one image file which can be
rendered for basically almost any kind
of screen size or zoom level or things
like that the vector graphic we'll be
creating today forms the basis of the
rocket ship animation in my jetpack
notes Android architecture components
application so just an important thing
to point out notice how this animation
scales really quickly and easily to a
variety of different screen sizes as you
can see here and so what I'll do is I'll
show you where I got the basis of this /
-
our image from
please visit the repository link down in
the description box below clone the
application and in this application
you're going to find a PNG image file
which is of course a raster graphic type
file and what I'd like you to do is go
ahead and download that repository and
this is the file that will be basically
turning into a vector drawable so you
don't have to download it from say open
clipart so if you happen to have a more
all-encompassing video editing software
tool like Photoshop or something like
that chances are it does have the option
to export from say a bitmap or PNG to an
SVG file or some other kind of vector
drawable if you have that option do
export to SVG and you can basically skip
this part of the tutorial I'm going to
be using Inkscape and the reason for
that is [ __ ] does not actually allow you
to export to SVG Inkscape is a free open
source software so that's why I chose it
in particular but you can use whatever
you prefer to create your vector
drawable so what you want to do is go
ahead and open up the particular PNG
file rocket underscore 1 PNG from the
repository and you're going to need to
select it so click on it and hit ctrl a
and then go to path trace bitmap now
there's a couple different options you
can select here you're going to of
course want to pick the option which
renders your image as you prefer I'm
going to select colors like so and as I
can see here that looks about right I'm
also going to click remove background
and then we'll hit OK to actually
execute the trace and it looks like it
has worked and now we have our traced
out SVG file going on here our
collection of paths and the last thing
we need to do is go to file save as and
you can just save it right into the same
drawable folder that you grabbed the PNG
file from I'm going to name it the same
thing just make sure that for the save
as type thing you have selected here
you're going to want to pick Inkscape
SVG alright so we've created our SVG
file through
skink scape but as you can see here it
has a whole bunch of metadata and crap
in here that we don't actually really
want to include in the thing that we'll
be using in our project so what we're
gonna do is you can just go right click
on resources or drawable select new
vector asset like so so just a quick
little tip here if you in the asset type
field here if you select clipart and
then you can and then click on this clip
art icon here you can actually select
from a whole bunch of pre-made icons and
then create vector assets in Android
studio out of those as well so just a
quick little tip you don't have to go to
the website and download these assets
you can do it right here and this is far
more efficient anyways we're going to go
to local file and so go ahead and give
the thing an appropriate name so I'm
going to call this we'll call it I am
for an image and we'll call it what was
it called let's say rocket one for
example and then we need to of course
select it find it in the path variable
here so we're gonna select rocket 1 SVG
like so this particular size variable
can be easily changed and it's not
actually that important I do like to
leave the opacity on 86% especially in
like a dark themed application like this
one so I'm gonna leave that at where it
is and we can basically just leave all
of these different defaults here once
that is selected we're just going to hit
next I'll pull this into view and it's
going to tell us that the output
directory is going straight into travel
that's totally fine res main is fine and
go ahead and hit finish so what that has
done is as you can see down here that's
created a new drawable this one's called
icy rocket one I thought I typed IM
rocket one but I'm totally confused now
anyways so what you can do is go ahead
and open up this thing and just notice
that it's also an XML vector drawable
file but it's just a little more
purpose-built for Android we have our
Android variables in here
and that's basically all we need to do
to import our SVG drawable into Android
studio and then now what we can do is we
can just refer to this particular XML
file like any other kind of drawable and
it should show up appropriately so one
of the easiest ways of thinking of in
designing animations is just to suppose
that we have a series of still images
being looped through over time kind of
like a projector with a film reel if you
ever go to the movies so what we're
going to do is we're going to create an
animation list XML file it's going to be
super easy and in this list will supply
a series of different drawables to
animate through and that's kind of how
will actually create the animation
effect so in Android studio what I'd
like you to do is you're going to right
click on the drawable folder go to new
drawable resource file and what we're
going to do is we're going to call this
thing rocket blue - I'm going to call it
that because there's already a file
called rocket loop and you can leave the
qualifiers in that as defaults so the
first thing I'm going to do is I'm going
to change this to an animation list as
you can see here and then in this
animation list is where we will supply
the different drawables that we want to
loop through so we're gonna create items
and we're gonna say item Android
drawable and so what we're gonna do is
I'm not going to show you the whole
process of creating all three different
drawables but what we want to do is we
want to supply our scalable vector
graphics here so the thing we had was I
am actually got turned into icy rocket
one and what we'll do so that's the one
we created in this tutorial I'm actually
just going to change this back to the
default so this is I am rocket one and
you can do this too if you downloaded
the repository or you can use the icy
rocket one I don't really care and then
what we're gonna do so we've supplied a
particular drawable then we want to
supply a duration in this case so I'm
going to type 200 which is about a fifth
of a second so this
is going to be a pretty quick animation
and then we can go ahead and close off
that particular XML tag there I'm going
to click at the end here and hit ctrl D
twice and that's just going to copy to
the next line and then of course we're
going to add I am rocket to and then I
am rocket three like so and that is it
for our animation list so go ahead and
create that and then finally we'll look
at how to actually access this thing in
the code alright so I've opened up
fragment no detail XML which is the
thing I demoed earlier and so what you
can do here is using either an image
button or in this case an image view
you're going to want to specify the
source of this particular view as being
the animation not of course the
drawables so go ahead and do that and
then what I'll do next is I'll show you
how to actually get hold of this thing
and start the animation in the Java or
Kotlin code
alright so I've opened up note detailed
view which is in the repository and what
we'll do now is we'll see how to
actually start our animation list going
so just a quick note here if you're
wondering why there isn't any fine view
by ID or anything like that going on in
this particular file it's because I'm
using Kotlin synthetic properties for
the user interface but in any case
however you prefer to get a hold of the
particular views in XML you're going to
want to do that if you have to use fine
view by ID that's fine so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to scroll down to the
function where we actually start this
animation drawable I'm just going to
give us some more room here so the way
that we actually start these drawables
going is you're going to want to get a
hold of the actual view which possesses
the animation and then you're going to
get a hold of the drawable so you could
say say in java i am i am be no detail
satellite get drawable or something like
that you're going to want to cast it to
an animation drawable this is how we do
casting in Kotlin and then the function
we want to call is start
so what that's going to do is in this
particular case that's going to start
our animation here going now in this
particular feature of the application
the animation just runs permanently just
as a little visual UI effect so I'll
show you a few other little options for
these particular animation list troubles
okay so what I've done is I've opened up
note ListView which has a few more
things going on with these particular
animation lists drawables or animation
drawables rather so first off I've
showed you how to start just a plain
animation there are other animations in
this particular application so there's
actually a background space animation
which is always looping and one thing in
particular I do with that and I've
actually just added this into an
extension function in Kotlin so I'll
show you what it does so basically if
you want to specify say a fade animation
then you're going to want to set the
enter fade duration set exit fade
duration and then that'll allow you to
fade between the particular drawables we
don't need to do that with the
rocketship animation but it works nicely
with our space loop animation and then
of course we call start to actually get
an animating now in this particular
feature depending on what goes on we do
need to actually stop the animation so
when you want to do that again you're
going to want to cast the drawable of
the view that possesses the animation
and then you just want to call stop as
we see here so that's basically it
so what we're going to do is we are
going to build the login form of the
space notes application quite
specifically we're going to be building
this layout and the purpose here is to
teach you some of the basics of applying
some principles of material design and
also the basics of using the constraint
layout effectively because one of the
things with the constraint layout is
that there's a way you can work with the
tool in the design editor where you're
clicking dragging like 50 different
constraints and attaching all these
things together and then more recently
they've added some features where we can
streamline a lot of it a lot of that
process so that'll be the main focus of
today's video also talked a little bit
about styles and a couple different
things like that but yeah let's get
started so before we build the layout
itself I wanted to talk about some
styles and resources that we'll be using
so we will be using animation drawables
for the animated background the space
animation and also for the antennae
animation and we'll also be using some
vector drawables for our icons and also
the antennae animation so if you're not
familiar with those topics what I'm
going to suggest you do is head over to
the previous video in this series number
three because in that video I cover how
to create vector drawables and animation
lists and how to do that with totally
free tools and if you're curious about
what a vector drawable is just go watch
that video but understand it's you don't
necessarily want to use them everywhere
but the benefit of using them is that
you can have one file which scales to
multiple different resolutions as
opposed to having to supply images for
each particular resolution so I
definitely consider checking that out
but what I'm going to ask you to do now
is in the description box below
there is a repository link to the
repository that'll be which contains the
code that we'll be working with so
hopefully you've already done this
before but if you haven't and you're
just jumping into this tutorial series
go ahead and clone or download that code
because that will be the basis from
which we
work from we'll also be using some
styles which are located in the view
styles XML file so the purpose there is
just to remove some redundant XML
attributes and try to get it so that if
I need to change something I'm only
changing it in one place I won't be
going into detail about that in this
particular tutorial but do consider
checking that out because as you'll see
we'll be adding some styles to our
layout files for that purpose alright so
the file that we're going to be
rebuilding specifically is fragment
login so hopefully at this point you
have downloaded or cloned the repository
if not you can of course still follow
along with what I'm doing here so yeah
as I say we're gonna be rebuilding
fragment logon and in order to have the
code easy for you to reference just go
ahead and right-click on the layout
folder go to new layout resource file
and we're gonna create a new one called
fragment underscore login underscore
demo like so and go ahead and set the
root element as a constraint layout
there's a couple different options here
so just make sure you select the
constraint layout but if you have to
change it later that's fine too there we
are and we are ready to get started so
first thing let's go ahead and give it
an ID here so I'm going to type ID at
plus ID and this one's going to be
called route fragment login just be
aware there's going to be some over
rights here because we have the same
layout in a different file but that
should make things a little bit easier
in terms of autocomplete so yeah we've
added an ID to that layout and then the
next thing we're gonna want to do is set
the background like so so the specific
background we're gonna be using is
called space loop like I said before if
you want a detailed explanation of how
to set these things up you can you're
gonna want to watch the previous video
but let me just open up space loop
really quickly here so that was just
ctrl shift and to open a file and this
is basically what it looks like here so
as you can see we've got a couple
different drawables the root tag is
animation list and the duration is
basically it's going to loop through
these animations kind of gradually this
will be a like a two second delay and
these drawables just so you're aware
these ones are
going to be PNG files where as we'll see
with the iconic animation they are
actually vector drawables so anyways so
what I'll do next is I'm going to click
on this image button and just click and
drag it into the top left corner of the
screen like so this is gonna open up a
dialog to select some kind of resource
so you can select some kind of pre-made
resources that they provide for you for
different just like kind of placeholders
and icons and all kinds of different
things in this particular case we also
have these really horrendously
weird-looking avatars I have a specific
file in mind which I've added ahead of
time so the drawable we'll be using in
this case is in the project tab and
we're just going to navigate to let's
see here this is going to be icy arrow
back black like so so I'm just gonna
click on that it's not actually black as
you can see here but that's fine so I'm
just going to click on that and hit the
ok button and that has added in this
particular image button drawable so what
we're gonna do first is I'm going to
show you one of the ways to kind of
manually set the constraints for a
constraint layout and then for the rest
of this particular layout we'll see a
way to do it way quicker that works in
certain situations so the first thing
I'm going to want to do is now that I've
dragged this thing into a particular
area of the screen I'm gonna want to
basically constrain the top of this view
to the parent top so I'm just going to
click and drag and then kind of bring it
to the top of the screen here can't
really see what's going on in this
editor so let me switch to the blueprint
editor here and I'm going to click and
drag to the left side of the screen and
as you can see that is constrained our
back button like so
and what I'm going to want to do is I'm
just going want to play with the margins
a little bit I think I'm gonna do 16 by
16 for the margins sorry for the very
crowded screen so we're almost done with
the image button and this is going to be
like our back button here well one thing
I wanted to do is I want to make it
that it's actually styled like a toolbar
button since we're kind of doing a
custom toolbar so one of the hacky but
totally legitimate ways I do that is I
type style so this isn't actually a
style which I created I'm just going to
type at style slash widget dot app
compat and then we're gonna select
action button so that's going to do a
couple of things it's going to remove
that ugly sort of dark gray background
it's also going to add things like an
animation when the image is clicked and
things like that so it's just going to
add a bunch of styling information and I
do recommend that you do that now in the
text editor we're also going to want to
rename this view so I'm gonna call this
thing I and B toolbar back like so and
that's basically all we need to do here
so one quick point you'll notice that
here Android studio has automatically
added this source compat attribute here
so this is because we're dealing with
vector drawables so just one quick thing
to point out here if you're basically
targeting applications on API lower than
21 then this thing isn't actually going
to work properly with all views and I'm
not sure if it actually is back ported
to everything but if you're using vector
drawables you're going to want to go to
your App level build.gradle file your
module level build.gradle file whenever
you've called it you're gonna want to
add in this vector drawable as equals or
vector drawables dots use support
library thing into your build.gradle
file now in this case because we are
only targeting API 21 and above I don't
think that's actually necessary but just
for backwards compatibility I wanted to
mention that okay so what we're gonna do
next is we're going to add a whole bunch
of different views to the layout and
we're not actually going to manually set
the constraints because that can be
quite tedious and instead we're going to
use one of the helpers in order to do
that for us but before I worry about the
constraints we're just going to add the
views into the layout set the IDS add a
little bit of design-time attributes so
we can get a rough idea of what it'll
look like and then we'll figure out how
to do the constraints
so I'm going to open up the pallet and
so we'll start with a couple different
things here so first and foremost I'm
gonna want text view and so our goal
here basically when we click and drag
these into the design time editor here
they're not constrained but they're
going to set like an absolute value of
where they're positioned so I just want
to kind of roughly position them where I
think I want them to go and that should
be adequate so we have our first sort of
login status drawable then we're going
to add in this is going to be an image
view so we'll go to common and it's of
course going to take us through the
dialog here so what we're gonna do for
this particular image view is it's going
to be antennae loop is the drawable that
we're looking for so again this is
actually an animation animation list and
resources and so I don't really want it
there let's just kind of position it
right there and we'll have to fiddle
around a little bit with some of the
attributes in a minute so I've got that
thing positioned there and then we have
another textview below that so I'm just
going to click and drag I know this
isn't super visible it's okay we'll
figure that out in a minute alright so
we've got that textview and then finally
there's a button so we're just gonna
click and drag that down to the bottom
and there we go so as you can see we
have a basic set up but everything is
really ugly so the next thing we'll do
is we're gonna hop into the text editor
and then just set a couple of things
very often what I'll do is I'll spend
most of my time in the text editor well
when it comes to like setting up the
actual constraints then oftentimes I
find it easier to do it in the design
editor so the first thing I'm gonna do
is I'm just going to fix all of the
different generated IDs so using
whatever convention you like as you can
see I have some habits of mine from
other platforms but we're going to type
lvl this one's going to be called login
status header then we have our image
view so I don't want this thing to be
wrap content wrap content this thing is
actually going to be a hundred and
twenty-eight
dip anyways we can fiddle with that in a
minute
for its ID that's going to be a MV
antennae animation like so so I'm trying
to find an adequate zoom level here
that's not too obnoxious and yeah then
we've got our text view so this one is
going to be called a BL login oops
login status display and then we have
our button at the bottom so this one is
going to be called BTN auth attempt so
you don't have to use my particular
convention for naming these IDs but I do
suggest you use a convention I'll
probably end up switching to camelcase
for these because using Kotlin synthetic
properties I end up having to have this
ugly underscore case in my caught
lungeing code so just something to
consider alright so I wanted to set the
IDs in particular before we go messing
around here with the constraint layout
editor because once the constraints are
set you need to mess around with the IDs
afterwards if you change them so now
that we've got that set let's happen
back into the e design time editor and
so in this case I see that the image
view has gotten positioned a little bit
weirdly so I'm just gonna again kind of
manually position these things where I
think I want them something about like
that and then what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to switch to the blueprint editor
here so we can have a pretty clear view
of what's going on and then what we'll
do is so I'm going to click on each of
these views and holding shift I'm going
to select all of them alright once we
have everything selected just right
click on one of the views and go to
chains and then we're going to create a
vertical chain so what that's done for
us is it's basically constrained all of
these views to each other and the parent
as you can see in this sort of chain so
let's just hop back into the design
editor for a min
so as you can see we have everything
kind of aligned horizontally the way we
want but the actual spacing here is
pretty ridiculous so what we're gonna do
is we're just going to click on this
little chain icon here and this is going
to change the type of chain so there's a
couple different options there is let me
just grab my notes so there's going to
be spread inside spread and packed in
this particular case we're probably
going to want packed I think that's not
it there we go something like that okay
so we've got these views roughly where
we want them what I'll do next is I'm
just gonna select each of them and then
we're going to constrain them
horizontally so again just click and you
holding shift select all of them this
can be a little bit tricky with these
buttons popping up just be aware that
and then once we have these things
selected I'm just going to right click
on them and then we're gonna go to
Center and then we're gonna select
horizontally and what that's going to do
is it's going to horizontally constrain
all of those views and as I said before
this is a lot quicker than having to do
this manually that's how I used to do it
and it works but it's kind of tedious so
one of the main takeaways here is just
learn a little bit about these different
options that they provide you in the
editor and see if you can use them to
expedite the process of building your
layouts a little bit quicker okay so
we've got everything roughly where we
want it to go so the last thing we'll do
is we'll play around with some of the
specifics here just to get a more
material design and stylish look so up
here we can probably add some design
time text to this particular view
actually this thing I believe is always
login status so we'll just set it to
that and it looks like that thing needs
a little bit bit of styling so I'm gonna
type style and we're going to use yeah
that's the one text stuff primary login
header and that should just give it a
larger font size as you can see here
it's looking a little bit better we'll
move down to the image view and for the
image view it's already pretty close to
being good to go
one
thing if I wanted to support tablets and
things like that I would probably not
want to actually hard-code these lay out
height and width values instead I would
want to provide them in resources but
like I say we're skipping a couple of
things here for the sake of the tutorial
anyways so what we want to change here
is that the sizing is all good but we
would prefer a white drawable in this
particular case on the dark background
so I'm going to type Android tint and
we're just gonna hard code in ffffff six
FS which is the hex code for white and
as you can see here that's looking like
that so let's move to the next text view
below so this one the text changes
frequently I'm just going to type tools
text instead and so we're going to type
signed in as one particular example
status and then we also have some
styling for this view so this one is I
believe text primary login header dot
sub yep that's looking a little bit
better and finally let's head down to
our button so I've made another special
style attribute for this thing which is
going to be style slash cloth button and
this is the button that I actually used
to trigger the Google sign-in so anyways
the text for this particular button is
going to be it changes frequently at
runtime but we're just going to type
tools text and then we're going to type
sign out like so and let's just have a
quick look at what that looks like all
right not looking bad so that's
basically it for the XML stuff here as
far as the layout is concerned I know
earlier I mentioned I wouldn't go into
detail about these Styles but I thought
I would just show you a little bit about
this particular file view styles.xml and
so one of the biggest tips I can give
you in terms of giving like a nice
material design look to your application
use the sans-serif
font families and that'll give you some
nice Roboto fonts and then also the
different sizes that I use to basically
come from the Android material design
documentation so well the Google's
material design documentation rather so
I do highly suggest you check that out
and just try to follow what they
recommend as best as you can but also
you know feel free to take some creative
license over what you do as well
also one quick point with styles that
you can actually use them like in sort
of a CSS way so you can overwrite
different values but also inherit from
parents and and stuff like that and I
use that quite frequently
and in today's video I'm going to be
showing you how to set up the navigation
component from andron jetpack so firstly
as of making this video the navigation
component does not work out of the box
with on activity result I did see a
couple people had some really hacky
shared mutable state solutions for
solving this problem but I wouldn't
actually recommend them when it's
actually easier to just not use the
library in the activity which receives
the result which is what I chose to do
in this particular application so that's
kind of one of my criticisms here is
there's kind of a strong push to move to
a single activity approach and this was
one case where I wanted to do that and
couldn't based on framework limitations
now like I say as I'm making this video
I have seen that there's some discussion
about adding integration with navigation
and on activity result possibly in later
versions although it doesn't appear to
be a very high priority anyways in
fairness if you're watching this video
several months or even years from now
there's a chance that it has been
integrated with the library and if
that's the case then that would make me
very happy I was also told recently by a
friend of mine Dov automatic who's an
awesome programmer that navigation does
not play nice with few pagers and
fragments so another thing to be aware
of so while I'm not really happy about
some pretty common use cases having some
problems with the library I think those
are things which hopefully will be
improved on over time so let me get to
the second reason why I'm not super
happy with the library so I just didn't
really feel like the steps required to
implement navigation and the fact that
we're basically pulling logic out of
Kotlin code or java code and putting it
back into hex ml was really worth the
effort of setting up relative to the
problems that our Doc's actually solved
in my applications so what I'm basically
saying here is what this library will do
for you is it'll allow you to basically
get rid of some of the fragment
transaction or start activity type logic
which you normally use to navigate to
different screens in your application
and so it's not that we're actually just
getting rid of all of that Lodge
in a sense we're basically pulling a
bunch of it out into an XML file and
then we're having this framework and
generate a lot of that logic for us now
if you get fast enough with the visual
editor and you're familiar with all of
the features you can actually write this
logic pretty quickly using the tool but
I just wanted to mention that relative
to say handwriting this code with Kotlin
extensions or something like that I
didn't feel like I saved much time okay
so with all that criticism in mind and
let's just keep in mind this is a fairly
new tool I did like the navigation
feature in the parts of the app where it
didn't cause any problems that it worked
quite well in that regard in particular
I do like the safe args option for
basically sending type safe arguments
between different screens of your
application and I will be demonstrating
that feature today finally if you would
like to follow along with this tutorial
please clone or download the repository
link in the description box down below
okay so the first thing we'll do is
we'll look at configuring this thing
with Gradle so in your build script
function here in your project level
build.gradle file we need to add a
particular configuration to the build
script dependencies in particular we
need to add this thing here and Droid X
dot navigation colon navigation safe
args need blah blah blah and once you
add this thing in that's going to allow
you to use the safe arts plugin and what
we'll do next is we'll see how to add
that to the module level build.gradle
file in the module level build.gradle
file you're going to want to add up at
the top here apply plugin and reduction
safe argh Scotland now if you're in Java
you're gonna want to probably delete the
dot Kotlin and I think that's the
appropriate plugin for Java anyways down
in the dependencies the two dependencies
that we'll really be working with are
the navigation - fragment - KTX and the
navigation - UI - KTX so again I think
if you're working with Java or something
like that you just delete the - KTX and
it'll work work for you but there is a
page where you can figure out the
particular dependencies so just go check
that out in the
documentation okay so let's get started
building out the navigation component so
the first thing we're going to need is a
navigation graph and this is basically
like an XML resource which specifies all
the different destinations which our
navigation component can travel to along
with plenty of other details so what I'd
like you to do so presumably you have
downloaded the repository so go ahead
and in the res navigation directory just
notice we have this file Navagraha CH is
what we will be building what we'll do
is we'll create another file so I'm just
going to right click on navigation we'll
go to navigation resource file and we're
gonna call this nav graph demo you can
call it whatever you like and so what
we'll do is we'll basically rebuild this
nav graph file over here and I just want
to have it there so that you can
reference it so here we have the
navigation editor so we've got a couple
different things here on the side panel
we have this destinations tab here and
as you can see we don't currently have
any destinations and no nav host
fragments is found so we can go ahead
and ignore that for a minute and what
I'd like you to do is we've got this new
destination button up here so go ahead
and click on that one and it's basically
what we're going to do is we're going to
add all the different fragments and/or
activities which we want to be able to
navigate to and these things are known
in this library as destinations
obviously so we'll need to add the note
detail view fragment then I'm just going
to add in the note list fragment and as
I mentioned before just due to the
integration limitations with on activity
result we're not actually going to jump
to the login view which is a fragment
we're actually going to have to jump to
the login activity so we'll just select
this option here all right so we've
added all the different destinations but
as you can see we have a little bit of
work to do so the first thing I'm going
to do is I'm basically just going to
click and drag these things storyboard
style and roughly where I want them so
we're going to drag login activity up
here and we'll note ListView is actually
kind of like the main sort of dashboard
of the application
we'll bring no detail of you down here
and before we do anything else I just
want to do a little bit of cleanup
okay so we've added our destinations but
I think we need to hop into the text
editor for a minute and just make a
couple of adjustments so I'd like to be
able to actually preview visually the
screens that are that the application
has in the each given destination and
one of the ways we can do that is we can
use this tools layout attribute here so
for those who aren't aware the tools
namespace is basically like a design
time namespace and whatever details you
add here actually get stripped out of
the packaged application so in this case
we don't actually want to refer to the
activity login layout because the
activity login is just a container what
we'll want is I believe it's called
fragment login here we go and as you can
see that should fix that up there we go
that's exactly what I'm talking about
there so we'll just add that in for the
other fragment destinations here so in
this one here I'll zoom in a little for
everybody so on that one that's going to
be fragment no detail and then up above
here fragment note list
all right loading and that's looking a
lot better except I think I've reversed
them okay so this is fragment no detail
you know I could edit this out but I'm
just gonna leave this in here that's
it's pretty spectacular tryin okay and
let's just hop back to the design editor
okay that looks more like it so as you
can see it's added a two onto these
names because we've already defined them
in the other file but that's totally
fine okay so the way that we actually
kind of define how to navigate between
these different destinations is by
setting up actions so the way that you
set up actions in the visual editor is
you'll notice a lot like constraint
layout each of these different
destinations will have this little thing
you can click on here so you can click
and drag
like that to a particular destination
and what that has done here is it's
added this arrow and the arrow basically
represents an action so go ahead and do
that now how this thing basically works
is that the note ListView is able to
jump to either the login activity or
it's able to jump to the note detail
activity so I'm just going to click
there again oh come on there we go
and I'm going to click and drag that to
the note detail view now in this
particular case once the user is done
messing around with the note detail view
either when they hit the delete button
kind of hard to see but yeah there's
either a delete or check mark button
there so once the user does that then
they're basically going to jump back to
the note list view so I'm going to
select no detail view and then I'm gonna
click and drag this one oh that's not
what I wanted to do and we'll just have
it point back to the note list view so
as you can see we've defined pretty much
all of the different actions or
navigation actions which we like the
application to be capable of
implementing there is one last thing we
need to do here though well there might
be a couple of things but what we need
to do is in this particular case often
what will happen is this is basically
like a list view and oftentimes the user
will be selecting an item in a recycler
view here and then we'll need to send
the ID of that item over to the note
detail view and this is a very common
pattern you'll see this all the time
it's a lot better than actually sending
the whole note item you just send the
idea over so what we can do there is
we're going to click on the action
between the note list destination and
the no detail destination here and I'm
going to click on the attributes panel
here and what we can do is we can
actually add some argument values to no
detail view sorry don't actually click
on the action here click on no detail
view and this is where we can add
arguments so in this tab here we have
arguments are just going to hit plus and
so the name of this argument is going to
be no
I D definitely try and give it a good
name of course the inferred type is
going to be a string sorry not the
inferred type the type is going to be a
string you can select inferred type but
we're just going to use some simple data
here and then it's not going to be
nullable and we don't really care
especially about a default value in this
case so yeah just go ahead and type note
ID select string as a type and hit add
and so just as a reminder to everyone
all of this stuff we're doing in the
visual editor is basically just creating
a whole bunch of boilerplate in the XML
for us so what we can do here is now
that I've added that particular argument
to our no detail view it's added this
little entry down here so that's
basically all we need to do to actually
configure this thing properly just one
final note here up in the top of the
navigation tab here we have this app
start destination attribute so this is
where you specify basically which
particular destination you want to start
the application from and then in this
case we don't want to start in no detail
view we want to start in the note list
view so I'm just going to type note list
view - or whatever name it has and
that'll be the starting point of the
application now when I say starting
point of the application that's assuming
that your applications manifest file
points to the activity which will be
basically like the host for our
navigation setup and we'll look at that
in a moment okay so now that we have
built out this particular XML file here
what I'm going to suggest you do is
unless you actually want to keep this
thing just for notes or something like
that please go ahead and delete this
file we just created because we want to
actually be using the old file just so
it works well with everything in our
application I just wanted to show you
the actual process of building out the
navigation graph using the design editor
alright so now that we've got our
navigation graph set up what we can do
is we can set up our nav host fragment
now again just a really quick bit of
practical information here what I would
suggest is so the one of the
of this particular library is to go for
a single activity approach I think
that's totally great except as I
mentioned before I literally wasn't able
to do that due to library limitation but
what I'm going to suggest to people is
for different features of your
application where you're running into
trouble with this particular library my
recommendation is to just pull that into
a separate activity and you can use you
can apply like a model-view-presenter or
whatever to that particular feature of
the application just have your
navigation graph point to its activity
instead of the fragment and then just do
what you would normally do and when you
need to jump back into the navigation
graph you're of course going to have to
start the sort of navigation host
activity which in this case is note
activity so it was enough rambling let's
go ahead and configure that note
activity and so the note activity
basically manages both the note detail
view and the note list view okay so what
we'll do is again we're going to create
an extra file which will delete
afterwards so just go ahead and
right-click on the layout here and we're
going to go to a new layout resource
file and this file is going to be called
activity note demo and for the route
layout we're gonna select a constraint
layout there we go and that's what we'll
start with here okay so what we need to
do here is we need to add this thing
called a nav host fragment and we could
add that manually but there's actually a
way to do it really quickly in the
design editor so in the palette here
just on the side there's the containers
menu here and in the containers menu
you're going to find down below this
thing called nav host fragment so what
you'll want to do is just click and drag
this nav host fragment we can Center it
doesn't really especially matter here
and it's going to give you a list of
navigation graphs to select from of
course select nav graph and as you can
see here it's done most of the work for
us we're just going to hop into the text
editor so for the layout width we're
going to say match pair
the same thing for the layout height and
there's a couple other things we can
just remove the absolute layout editor
here so we're specifying the navigation
graph that we built we have this thing
set as the default nav host so this is
kind of like a default configuration
which will work kind of easier and then
also when we see this Android name
attribute this actually refers to the
particular class name of whatever
fragment so in this case just note that
nav host fragment is not something that
we are going to actually create we're
going to use the default implementation
and this is basically how we point to it
up here now in this application we of
course call this thing fragment it can't
type fragment nav but yeah this is
basically all the configuration we need
to do and then what you can do is just
go ahead and delete this file or keep it
if you like okay so the next thing we
need to do is we need to have a nav
controller which generally speaking will
be an activity so what we're gonna do is
in the note package of our main package
here just open that up and so the file
will be rebuilding it won't take long is
note activity and again what we'll do is
just right click on note go to new
Kotlin or Java class whichever you
prefer go to a note active type note
activity demo and don't worry about
actually creating a proper activity and
adding it to the manifest okay so what
we'll do next is we'll just take class
note activity demo and then that thing
is going to extend app compat activity
like so give it a constructor and the
particular function that we're going to
need to add in here is we'll need to
override on create so usually it'll auto
complete for us here let's see let's go
with this option here okay so what we
basically need to do here is we need a
nav controller object which fortunately
is super easy to correct or to create
and what we'll basically do is when we
need to actually perform these
navigation operations will be basically
getting a hook
- this nav controller through the
library so anyways what you need to do
is go ahead and add private late in a
bar now and that's going to be of type
nav controller like so then we need to
create the snap controller so we'll say
nav equals navigation dot find nav
controller and what we'll do is we'll
pass this forward the activity and then
it also requires a layout res ID which
is the nav host fragment and so the
Navajos fragment is basically what what
we sort of swapped the views in and out
of so in that case that thing is called
r dot ID dot fragment now like so so
it's complaining that I need to import
our but I'm just not going to worry
about that if I hop over to note
activity as you can see that's actually
all we need to do and this was one part
of setting this thing up that was
actually like really quick and painless
so now that we've got that done we can
actually take a look at how to actually
use this library in action ok so I'm
going to open up a note list view and
we'll look at some different ways to
actually use this library to navigate to
different destinations so I'm going to
hit ctrl n note list view and we'll just
look at two particular situations here
so in the first case we have a situation
where we're basically just navigating to
a particular destination without any
arguments so there's actually a lot of
different options we have as we can see
for navigation so basically how this
tool pretty much works is at least when
we're calling it from a fragment here we
have this fine nav controller function
so what happens is we call fine nav
controller and that's of course going to
through the framework grab this thing we
have here in the activity and then we
can perform navigate operations among
other things to jump to different
destinations so this is almost kind of
equivalent to like saying start activity
except we're not working with activities
here so I just want to bring your 10
so if I click within the parentheses of
this navigate function here and hit ctrl
P I just want you to notice that there
are a lot of different options for what
you can pass here so in a really simple
case we basically just pass it the ID of
a particular destination so we have our
ID login view if I hop into the nav
graph here just notice that if we go to
this activity the ID of this destination
is login view so that's where that's
coming from so that's kind of the first
case now what about when we actually
want to pass arguments type safe
arguments to a particular destination
and let me tell you this is one of the
things that I actually quite liked about
this library and probably the main
reason why I'm actually telling this
video to be honest is the safe arguments
feature here so when you want to
navigate with arguments to a particular
feature so in this case we want to go to
the note detail view and here and we
need to pass some kind of ID to it so
when we're creating a new note so when
the user hits the create new this is
like a floating action button and they
want to create a new note
then we pass just an empty note ID and
just understand that on the other side
note act note detail fragment and it's
view model is going to be aware that
this is a new note so that's just in
case you're wondering why we're passing
that now what we need to do when we
actually want to jump to a particular
destination with arguments is we need to
use this note list view directions dot
action note list view to note detail
view where the hell did that come from
obviously we didn't write that so this
is kind of one of the main points of
this library is that the work you do in
the XML will generate some functions
like this that you can use to perform
these different navigation operations so
obviously in the simple case we can just
call navigate in this case we need to
use these note this note list view
directions object and where this
function came from and this our sorry
where this class came from and this
function of the class came from is based
on some generated code from
our XML configuration here so with that
in mind you may need to build your
project in order to actually create
these things because I'm pretty sure
they're made at compile time so in this
case once we've created our direction
and we've given it the particular action
and the arguments that are required of
that action and all of this has been
generated for us then we passed that
direction object to hour-and-a-half
controller and then that's how we
actually get to the other fragment with
the arguments okay so the last thing
we'll do is we'll look at how to get the
arguments out of our receiving
destination which in this case is of
course a fragment so I'm going to scroll
down to the view model dot handle event
function here that's within on start and
so basically what goes on is we have
this note detail view args object which
is of course generated for us then we
call dot from bundle and we supply the
arguments property of this fragment and
then where does dot note ID come from so
this is actually the name of the
arguments that we defined in the nav
graph as you can see here and in this
case once we grab those arguments we
just pass them to the view model in the
form of a sealed event class and then
the application figures out what to do
from there
and in this video I'm going to be
talking to you about using fragments as
views in model view viewmodel
architecture and we'll also look at how
to use Kotlin synthetic properties to
eliminate boilerplate UI code and refer
directly to XML views now how this is
going to work is in this video we will
write the fragment and then of course in
the next video we will write the view
model which our fragment currently talks
to before we get to coding the fragment
I just wanted to talk about model view
viewmodel architecture for a moment so
as discussed in the second video in this
series and you should probably go and
watch that if you haven't and you're
curious about this particular pattern
there's a couple really subtle ways to
do it differently which don't actually
break the pattern entirely so I won't be
going into great detail on this but
basically what I'm saying here is the
style of view model and view that we're
going to be writing today is basically
such that it allows the view to be very
simple and easy to write and easy to
test at the expense of moving a lot of
the presentation logic of the view in
the view model it'll basically simplify
construction of the view but the key
point here is the more details are the
more presentation logic we include about
a specific view in a view model the less
reusable the view model becomes so what
I'm saying here is if you have a view
model which you plan to use for a
variety of different views you're going
to want to take the other approach that
I discuss not the one where you have
lots of details about the view in the
actual view model just so there's no
confusion about what I just said there
let's have a quick look at two different
view models in this project so the one
we'll be writing
today or sorry the one that our fragment
that we write today
will be talking to and the one we'll
write in the next video is the user view
model so the thing about this view model
is in keeping with the pattern it does
not directly reference any particular
view however it does have like I said
before specific details about a
particular view so we see fields in here
like sign-in status text
off button text satellite drawable so as
you can see this view model is going to
work really well with a particular view
but it's not necessarily going to be
something that we can reuse with a whole
bunch of different views when I open up
note view model I basically you will
pretty much not see any specific details
about a particular view within reason so
we're not going to see these show error
State type functions we are going to see
things like note was deleted note was
updated and we'll see that we do
actually publish a note object to
whatever observable is or sorry whatever
observer is listening but the thing
about this is by taking this approach of
having more reusable view models we're
now relying on the fragment or the view
to basically handle this presentation
logic okay so if you would like to
follow along with this tutorial and I do
suggest you do if you're going to watch
it then check out the description box
down below you'll find a link to the
open source code repository and you can
either clone or download it anyways what
we'll be looking at first is how to
configure Kotlin synthetic properties in
Gradle so the first thing you need to
make sure is that you have the Kotlin
Gradle plug-in installed this one here
sorry my word rap is kind of screwed up
so if you check marked the box that your
project is supposed to be a Kotlin
project in Android studio most likely
you won't actually have to add this in
manually it should be there if you've
configured a Kotlin project in a more
recent version of Android studio but I
just want to point this out in case
there's any confusion secondly one thing
you probably will need to add is go
ahead and open up the app level
build.gradle file and this is true for
whatever module you might want to use
the Kotlin synthetic properties in
you're just going to want to apply this
particular plug-in here Kotlin Android
extensions apply plugin and that will
allow you to use Kotlin synthetic
properties so the view class that we'll
be reading today is called login view
and I just want to make one more final
note here there are two functions in it
so in particular I'm talking about start
sign and flow and on activity result and
we're actually not going to be coding
out those two functions and the reason
why is that I'm going to go over those
when I talk about implementing firebase
with Google sign and provider so we
won't be coding these two functions here
in this video but like I say we'll get
to that eventually okay so what I would
like you to do to get started here is
you can either make a new file with a
slightly different name for login view
because that's what we'll be rebuilding
or what you can do is you can just
select everything under the package
declaration here to scroll down and have
a good delete and that will be our
starting point for today's tutorial
alright so the first thing we'll be
doing is we'll write out the class
declaration so go ahead and take the
class login view extends fragments like
so just line that up a little better and
of course we will have to import the
appropriate library so in my case I'm
using the Android X libraries so go
ahead and pick that so the next thing
we'll need to do is we want to add a
reference to our view model and we'll
have to use a late init bar for that
also in general since I don't want
anything else kind of messing around
with this particular reference we're
gonna make it private private basically
just means that we can only see it in
this particular class all right so when
we're working with fragments we need to
tell the fragment which layout to
inflate now if you're using data binding
there's a slightly different process for
this but what we're going to do today is
we are going to override the on create
view function like so and really
appreciate that autocomplete there
alright so go ahead and select
everything after this return statement
here and delete that so what we're going
to do instead is we are going to inflate
a specific layout so we're going to take
the past in inflator and we're gonna say
inflator dot inflate
and the resource we're going to give it
is we're going to point to the fragments
layout file so we're going to type r dot
layout dot fragment vloggin now it's
going to be complaining because it wants
to import R so you can go ahead and do
that I just hit alt enter there to
import it and that's satisfied that
particular problem and then we need to
give the container so this is where the
view will be inflated into and then
we're gonna type false for attach to
route now this particular option falls
for attach to route can be a little bit
confusing for people but just understand
that most of the time you want to leave
it false and it will still actually
appropriately add our fragment to the
activities view hierarchy so don't worry
about it anyways what we'll do next is
we'll begin writing out our on start
function so again I'm going to type
override fun on start like so and so
what we need to do at this point is
we're gonna already start to refer to a
couple different views in the XML layout
from our on start function here so what
we need to do is we need to set up our
synthetic functions now luckily this is
like seriously one of the easiest things
to do ever once you've added the library
as we discussed before so all you need
to do is just go up to your import
statements here so what we're going to
write is we're going to type import
Coughlin's X dot Android dot synthetic
dot main dot fragment login dot asterisk
so in case you're curious the asterisk
is basically saying whatever is a for
lack of a better term member of fragment
login then we want to import all of
those things so effectively what that's
going to do is if I open up fragment log
in here which is the actual view
so I took a while to load so basically
what's going to happen is we can now
refer explicitly to these particular
view IDs we don't don't need to do any
find view by ID stuff all we need to do
is just add in the appropriate layout
and we're good to go okay so what we're
gonna do now is we are going to assign
our view model now we'll type the code
out here by hand but I'm actually going
to be covering how to actually set the
dependency injection and view model
provider stuff up in a different video
so if you're curious about how to do
this in more detail I will eventually
get to that covering a lot of stuff in
this tutorial so what we can do is we're
going to type view model of course
referring to our reference above then
we're gonna say equals view model
providers with an S oh and then for this
particular thing let's just go ahead and
import that so it stops screaming at me
we're gonna type this passing in our
fragment again I'm not going to go into
detail about this we're just going to
take this out all right and then we'll
type login injector which is a custom
written dependency injection class which
extends Android view model so when we do
that we need to type require activity
this might be a new function for some
people around here I'll get into that
when I talk about this particular code
in the other tutorial but this is kind
of a handy little function that's been
added somewhat recently and then we're
gonna refer to the that's going to get
our activity and then we get the
application and then once that happens
there's one function in this particular
class login injector which is provide
users view model factory like so now
we're not totally done yet because we've
configured that aspect and now what we
need to do is we need to type dot get on
our view model providers and then we're
going to pass the specific view model
that we require here so we're going to
type user view model which is the view
model that we will be talking to and we
need to kind of refer to the class file
here so what we're going to do is we're
going to type double colon class dot
Java like so this
the things about Kotlin the the when you
need to reference a particular java
class
the syntax for it is kind of wonky but
whatever it works so that's all we need
to do to assign our view model our first
order of business now is going to be
starting the background animation so if
i briefly look at the layout that we're
writing the fragment for or vice versa
you understand what i mean it has a
background which is like a space
background basically and in the
application it actually kind of animates
if you're wondering how i did that i did
cover vector drawables and animations in
a particular video in this series i'm
sure you're tired of hearing that but
yeah go and watch that video if you want
to figure out how to do that in detail
so we're gonna need to cast it as an
animation drawable so type brackets
first and then what we'll type is root
fragment oops I can't fragment root
fragment there we go holy crap that was
pathetic and then so what we need to do
is we want to get a hook to the
background of this layout the space loop
drawable here so what we can do is we're
going to type root fragment log in so
we're referring specifically to this
layout and then we're going to type dot
background which is going to return a
normal drawable now this the thing we
have in this drawable is actually an
animation list so what we can do is
we're going to type as sorry animation
drawable is what I'm in animation
drawable okay and then what we're going
to do is we're going to type dot start
with fade so immediately you're going to
be wondering Ryan what the hell is start
with fade so it's actually just an
extension function that I wrote in this
project so I'm going to hit ctrl shift
in and we'll type Android and then
there's a file called Android extensions
in the common package and you'll notice
it has this particular function here
start with fade so all it does is
instead of having to repeatedly write
this code out I've just pulled that code
out and put it in an extension function
which just means that I can just type
start with fade and have instead of
having to type this crap here so there's
no magic this well there's the
and recov Kotlin extension functions
which are really like but there's
nothing too crazy going on here so the
next thing we'll do is we will set up
our click listeners and kind of bind
them to the view model appropriately so
since there's a couple of lines in that
function or there's a number of things
we need to do in order to set that up
we're gonna create a helper function so
we're just gonna call this thing set up
oops set up click listeners I've got my
keyboard in an awkward position and it's
just ruining my typing skills my
apologies
set up cliffs click listeners like so
and then I'm just going to click on that
hit alt enter create function and that's
going to build it down there and then
this is what we'll do next so like I
said before now that we have Kotlin
synthetic properties set up we can just
refer directly to the XML IDs so the
first one we're gonna assign is the off
button so that's going to be this button
in particular here the it thing that
currently says sign out but what it says
changes frequently so we're gonna type
BTN underscore auth attempt let it
autocomplete dot set on click listener
and we're gonna give it a lambda
expression here and so what we want to
do when this onclicklistener fires it's
going to basically call the code in our
lambda that's how this kind of works in
that event we want to type view model
dot handle event so this is basically
like a generic function which you'll see
in all of my view models and how they
work let me just pull the code up really
quickly here okay base view model so
we'll go into more detail about this in
the next video but just so you
understand what's going on here we have
this abstract function handle event and
it takes some particular type so let's
have a quick look at the view model
itself that we're going to be working
with that's again going to be user view
model and just notice that it extends
base view model and the generic type
which I pass for each given view model
is some particular kind of sealed class
which represents different events I know
this is a lot but
just understand that what this Login
event thing does is it basically just
represents different events which could
possibly propagate from a particular
view or a set of views so I just wanted
to show you the code really quickly so
you know what's going on here anyways
back to our view so we're going to call
our view model dot handle event function
and what we're going to pass that is
login event dot on/off button click so
this is basically our way of telling the
user view model hey someone just clicked
the off button so you need to do
something so that's not the only thing
we need to assign here Willer we're also
going to basically make it so that if
the user hits the back button then it's
going to start the list activity so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to type IMD
toolbar back is what it's called dot set
onclicklistener there we go again lambda
that [ __ ] pardon my language and then
what we're going to do is we're going to
type start list activities so this is
actually a function we will code so I'm
just going to hit alt enter create
function start list activity down below
so we're gonna use Kotlin single
expression syntax so we're gonna type
require activity again dot start
activity and in our start activity block
we're just going to go ahead and create
an intent so we're gonna say intent and
then in this intent we're gonna type
activity which is basically the activity
for this particular fragment then we're
going to type where we want to get to
which is note activity and then we'll do
our handy reference a Java class syntax
like so and that'll need to be imported
okay so with that when someone hits the
back button they're going to be sent to
the note activity now some of you may be
warning hey I thought you were using
navigation in this particular library
well actually because of limitations
which I discussed in the video where I
covered the navigation library we do use
the navigation library but not in this
particular feature of the applique
Asian and the reason is because it
doesn't play nice with on activity
result okay so we're almost done with
our setup click listeners function
there's just one more thing we need to
do we need to intercept on back pressed
and the reason for that is just because
of the awkward integration with the
navigation library which is not really
my fault so we're gonna save require
activity and then we're going to type
that dot aw add a hon back pressed call
back I can't talk today for some reason
so we're gonna have to monkey around
with this a little bit so we're going to
basically put some parentheses here
around our lambda we will still need the
lambda expression so for the first
parameter we're going to type view
lifecycle owner and that's a property of
our fragment here so if you're wondering
where that's coming from that's where
it's coming from and then we need to
create an on back pressed call back from
our lambda so we're going to type on
back pressed callback actually Auto
completed this time that was handy and
then what we'll do inside of this on
back pressed callback is we're going to
type start list activity and this
thing's complaining because this
function must return a boolean and the
boolean that we'll be returning is true
so the reason why we return true here is
because we're basically telling the
opera's operating system hey don't worry
about handling that back click event
we've got to cover don't do your thing
anyways let's move on here so the next
thing we'll do is we're going to write
our basically another helper function
called observe view model and what this
particular function is going to do is we
are going to observe some view models so
I'm just going to hit alt enter create
function down below so basically what
we're going to be doing here is we want
our view to pretty much attached to if I
can find it here pretty much every
publicly visible observable that our
user view model possesses so basically
what that's going to look like is we're
going to be typing view model
so the first one will do is sign in
status text dot observed so we're gonna
pass view lifecycle owner which is a
property of this fragment so it knows to
pay attention to that particular
lifecycle and then we're going to create
an observer lambda function and so again
this is basically just what do we do
when this particular observable
publishes data so how do we handle the
data and this is where this particular
style of view model is really quite
handy because basically all we do is we
just bind it directly to whatever gets
passed in so in this case I'll type up
here that if you don't understand how
lambda syntax works just understand that
whatever gets passed in here is inferred
to be this variable called it so for the
first one I'll actually give it a
different name than it we're just gonna
call this text and then I'm gonna hit
the arrow thingy here and then we're
gonna type we're gonna leave it like
that and that's going to assign the name
text instead of just using I T I'm just
doing this so hopefully you kind of
understand what's going on so this
particular field that we're working with
here basically dictates what is
displayed in this textview down here and
oh that's hard to see but this basically
login status display down here so what
we can do is we can refer to that
particular view so lvl login status
display and we're gonna get its text
property and we're gonna sign that to
text so for the rest of them we're gonna
use the it syntax but I just wanted to
demonstrate that here in case anyone's
confused about that I did do a video
about that what what does it mean in
Kotlin so you can go and check that out
if you like so what we'll do is we'll
type out another observable here so
we're going to type viewmodel dot off
button text so this is going to be the
text for this button here that currently
says sign out and it's the same process
here so we're going to type observe give
it the view lifecycle owner give it a
hook to our fragments lifecycle and then
we're going to give it another
server and in that observer so now we're
referring to a BTN off the temp and then
we're going to say dot text equals it so
the rest of this observe view model
function is just a whole bunch more live
data a dot observed functions so there's
nothing really new there and I don't
think there's actually any point in us
typing that code out together what I'm
going to suggest is if you would like to
practice maybe try implementing the rest
of this function yourself and what you
need to do is you basically you just
need to write one of these statements
one of these observed statements for
basically everything you see here now
just one important thing to note these
two live data observables here as
opposed to well actually this one does
affect the user interface but this one
in particular is actually just a way to
communicate back to the view based on
what happens in a particular off state
so we're going to learn a little bit
more about that in the next video where
we actually write out this view model
but yeah that's basically all I wanted
to cover in this particular tutorial
and you're watching video number seven
of my android 2019 tutorial playlist so
in this video we're going to be looking
at wiring up the view model and in the
previous video number six basically
we'll be writing the view model that we
hooked our fragment up to so if you're
curious about how to actually write the
fragment that this particular view model
is going to publish events to or data to
then you'll want to go back and watch
that video first now once again before I
proceed if you haven't already watched
video number two where I go into detail
about the model view viewmodel
architecture on Android you might want
to watch that first and the reason why
is it's important you understand that
there's a couple different ways to do
the interaction between the fragment and
the new model or the view in the view
model in general and the approach we're
going to be taking today is basically
good in a situation where you don't need
to reuse your view model and you would
prefer to have a fairly simple view
which doesn't have a whole lot of logic
so basically like a explain in detail in
that video what we'll be doing today is
we'll write a view model which basically
allows us to pull pretty much almost all
of the presentation logic of the
fragment the view go to the view and the
good thing about this approach is that
we can still maintain the model view
viewmodel pattern by communicating with
the fragment only through live data
objects so like I said in the previous
video you can also use data binding but
today we're just going to be using live
data to communicate between the view
model and the fragment alright so before
we proceed you may want to grab the
repository or the code that we'll be
working with today linked down in the
description box below and you're going
to want to either clone or download that
particular project and pull it up an
Android studio or whatever is your
preferred IDE anyways before we get to
the specific view model that we'll be
reading today I wanted to show you the
abstract class called base view model
which the v-model that will be writing
extends so we're not actually going to
write this class
out but what I wanted to do is basically
just talk about it really briefly and
what it does for us so there's a couple
different options for extending the
functionality of existing sources in
Kotlin and when we want to really
object-oriented solution one of the best
ways to do that is with an abstract
class so the purpose of this base view
model class is basically anything that
is going to be common to basically every
view model in this application I want to
include that in the abstract class so if
you'd like a detailed explanation of
this kind of thing I do go into detail
about all kinds of different things
including how to achieve similar
behavior with extension functions in my
Kotlin course like in the description
box down below so do consider checking
that out anyways what we're looking at
here is our base view model class
basically is going to be containing
co-routine context object and it extends
of course view model from architecture
components and then it also extends
co-routines scope so the reason why I
wanted to bring this up is it's
important you understand that this is
how or where we're going to kind of
launch our co-routines from now I'm not
actually going to go into detail on
coroutines in this particular video I
will go into more detail in another
video in this series but just understand
that when we look at a particular view
model so for example we have our
co-routine scope set up in this class
and then we have our routine context
down here and just notice it's going to
be basically placed on the UI context
dispatchers dot main thread and then we
have our job tracker object which allows
for cancellation functionality so when I
open up a particular view model which
basically that's not a view model good
job right when I open up a particular
view model which extends our base view
model just and understand that every
time we're making this launch builder
here it's going to be an extension on
our route co-routine scope so anyways
I'm not going to go into more detail on
that
in this video but I will talk about that
in detail in another video and I just
wanted to mention it here in case you're
wondering why is the launch thing all
yellow here that basically means that
it's an extension on our view model so
one other thing I would like to mention
so the thing about working with this
view model is obviously our live data
objects have to be publicly visible but
since we're not returning live data
objects from the back end we have to
work with mutable live data so one
suggestion from Al Warren who's been a
really awesome contributor to the wise a
slack Channel he just mentioned that one
of the ways you can kind of get around
this issue of having a publicly visible
mutable live data object is to basically
make the live data field which is
publicly visible or the live data
reference rather you basically make the
actual data the actual mutable live data
object as what you would maybe call an
implicit backing field in technical
language but basically what we're
talking about here is this thing here
the error State which is the mutable
object and we'll see a couple different
examples of this we can kind of hide
those behind hide them the mutable live
data reference behind a immutable live
data publicly visible reference so
basically what I'm saying here is if you
want to improve your encapsulation then
do consider taking this particular
approach here all right so the class
we'll be riding today is user view model
so there's kind of two ways you can do
this so I'm assuming you've downloaded
or clone the repository or you can just
watch if you like but you can either
basically just delete everything in here
except for the package statement up top
or you can just create a new file maybe
call it log in view model and build them
kind of side-by-side whichever you
prefer today what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to just actually select everything
here and delete it now before I do that
I just want to mention very briefly one
thing we're not going to code today in
this particular view model is the on
sign-in result function now the reason
for
that is that I'm going to be covering
that in the part of this tutorial where
we discuss using firebase and Google
sign and provider anyways with that
being said I'm just going to delete
everything there maybe I'll leave this
comment up top just for the fun of
things and we can get started building
our view model so the first thing we'll
do is we'll build out our class
declaration so we're going to type class
login view model actually sorry user
view model probably should have picked a
better name for it so we've got login
view model and this thing is going to
extend our base view model class now
when we extend the base view model if I
just talk back to it really quickly we
have this function here abstract fun
handle event and then we also have
what's known as a generic type so
basically what this is all about is that
T is going to be some kind of sealed
class which represents different events
which can propagate from the user
interface so we won't write that
particular class but I'll just show you
what it is in this particular case so
it's going to be a login event class let
me actually just pull that sealed class
up so you know what's going on so we've
got login event and so you as you can
see just a pretty run-of-the-mill sealed
class here now one of the things to
mention is that we in some cases will be
returning this login result class here
so that's just basically like a data
wrapper essentially so it just maintains
a request code and a user token so this
is the stuff which we'll be dealing with
in the firebase video but again since
we're kind of using it in this
particular tutorial I just wanted to
briefly mention what it is so we've got
a not too many different events here
just the three so there's on/off button
click on start and on Google sign-in
result and these are all events if I
open up so this is going to be fragment
login so that's basically all the events
for this particular layout here back to
our user view model
all right so we have our login event
class and because we have that one type
in here we do need to supply a
particular type for our co class so that
one is going to be a login result like
so and then we need our constructor or
initializer I think it's actually called
and that's not all of those so I'm just
gonna give our curly brackets here so
base view model is expecting a Co
routine context object so what we're
going to do is we're gonna basically
pass in a reference here called UI
context which is going to extend Co
routine context and so that's going to
get passed into our view model here so
in our base view model here that's going
to get passed in so during testing we
would basically want to mock or fake
this particular object and return
dispatchers dot unconfined but when the
application is actually deployed then
this is going to be basically running on
the main thread or rather our core
routine scope will be scoped to the main
thread anyways back to our user view
model all right so we've got our UI
context object so what we need to do is
we don't actually want to hold on to
this thing in our actual view model we
just want to pass that thing to the
superclass here the base view model
class so I'm just going to type UI
context and that should satisfy that
particular error and now it's going to
screen at us because we need to
implement our handle event function so
I'm going to click on that hit alt enter
and then implement members handle event
and then we have our handle event class
with the appropriate sealed class
accompanying it all right now there's
one more thing we need to do with our
constructor so the way that we actually
get data basically in and out of this
particular view model is through a
repository again I will go into more
detail on this in its own particular
video in this series but what we're
going to do is we're going to type Val
ref oh and that's going to be of type I
user
taury all right so we'll actually get to
coating our handle event function a
little bit later
what I wanted to start with here is the
various view model objects or sorry the
various mutable live data objects that
will need to be working with
so let me write one out here and then
we'll talk about how this kind of works
so the first one we're gonna write is
the actual data model which this
particular view model holds on to and we
are going to make that one private
because I don't want that one to be
tampered with whatsoever except for
within this particular view model class
so we're going to type private Val user
state and that's going to equal mutable
live data and the type is going to be
user so if you're not familiar with live
data so basically how this works is it's
going to pretty much wrap some kind of
object it could be a string in this case
it's the user data model I'll just open
that up really quickly here and it's
just like a really simple data class
which has a UID and a name so this
mutable live data is going to basically
wrap that object it's complaining
because I need to add that and then
that's how we'll actually kind of
persist the data in this view model now
some of you might be wondering what's
the difference between mutable live data
what's and live data and when should you
use them so I would basically put it
like this live data is essentially an
immutable class so basically what that
means is that you can't change a live
data object sort of within the class
that's holding it so what you can do is
let's say hypothetically we were
actually working with a user data model
which was coming in from a back-end tool
like say room so the important thing to
know here is if we were returning a live
data object from the backend then you
would want to make this live data but in
this particular case since we're
returning an object just the user object
which isn't a live data object that
means we need to make our live data
mutable so this basically means as you
see in a moment that we can actually
from with
this class change the particular value
that immutable live data object wraps
okay so we've made our actual data model
wrapped by a mutable live data object
and then what we need to do is we
basically need to write out a couple
different more live data objects with
the goal of basically covering all of
the different widgets and control
operations control logic which our view
will need to implement or or listen to
essentially okay so what this particular
thing is going to look like is we're
gonna type internal Val off oops
off attempt so the reason why we're
using internal is I basically want these
things to be visible by anything within
this particular module so for example
our fragments but just for better
encapsulation we're making it invisible
outside of any outside of any other
context so anyways we've got internal
Val off attempt and then that's going to
equal mutable live data again now for
the type here we're going to use unit so
why exactly would I use unit this is
very similar to like void in Java not
exactly the same but quite similar in
fact it does get mapped to void in when
it's D compiled into Java anyways how
this thing basically works is I suggest
using unit when you want to trigger some
kind of event but you don't actually
care about any particular value being
passed into that event so what I think
I'll do is I'll just show you really
quickly what this looks like in the view
so if I look at off attempt here just
notice that we're not actually returning
any kind of value there is kind of an it
which is of type unit that will get
passed in here but in this particular
case all we want to do is we just want
to call a particular function when this
particular mutable live data is changed
so we're changing it and triggering the
function but we're not actually changing
it to a particular value anyways what
I'll do next is I'm just going to hit
control just put my mouse right there
and then I'm going to
control D which will copy the line and
then we're going to have a second
control logic observable here so this is
going to be called start animation and
again that's just going to return unit
same idea alright so we have our two
control logic fields here or observables
or whatever the hell you want to call
them and in case there's any confusion
here the reason why we're doing this is
we need some way to call back to the
view so in this way we can call back to
it indirectly anyways we need a couple
more mutable live data objects so in
this particular style of building view
models we basically want a live data
object to represent every item in the
layout that we're dealing with here so
I'm just gonna again open up its two
control-shift-n and let's see fragment
logon so what I'm saying here is we
basically the way I actually built this
thing is I said okay for every item in
this layout every widget which changes
we need a mutable live data object to
basically represent the value that it
will have so in this particular case we
have this animation drawable here we
have this text view which basically just
displays the current login status and
then we have this off button down here
which is how we trigger off events and
this thing's text will change as well so
it follows that we'll need a mutable
live data object for each of these
things so what we'll do is so I'm just
going to type UI binding here because
that's basically what we're doing and
then we're gonna again use internal Val
sign-in status text so that'll be for
our sign-in status text view and that's
going to be a mutable live data object
and it's going to be of type string
perfect now
since even the animation drawable we're
going to be giving it a URL to a
particular resource all of these things
are going to be strings so again I'm
just going to hit ctrl D twice like so
and we're just gonna update the names
here so the first one is gonna be off
button text and by the way pick good
names for these things like don't don't
do short ugly names that leave people
guessing about what they mean then we
have this satellite drawable like so I
can actually probably pick a better name
for that one too to be honest but that's
okay good enough alright so we have our
live data objects and then what we'll do
next is we'll get started kind of
working with our handle event function
here alright so what we'll do next is we
will code our handle event function and
that way you'll get to see our sealed
class in action how it actually works so
what we're gonna do so there's a couple
different things going on here
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
stub out the presentation logic
functions and then we'll kind of
implement those towards the end here but
we can actually get started with them so
we're just gonna type show loading State
and I'm going to hit alt enter create
function show loading state and I'm
actually just going to leave this titute
to do function here this is actually
quite a handy function because if we do
end up calling this particular function
when we've forgotten to implement it
then we will actually get an error
popping up which is actually what we
want we want to know if this thing has
been implemented or not before we ship
the application so anyways we're
actually gonna as I say we're gonna
implement these functions a little bit
later what we'll do now is so this is
kind of the the main point of using a
sealed class is we can represent a
number of different finite states that
the sealed class can represent and that
can represent different events in the
front end or back end of an application
so I use sealed classes all of the time
and if you're not familiar with them you
probably should be if you're writing
Collin so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna use a when match or sourcing when
the event which is what is passed in
here then we'll give it some curly
brackets and then this is where we list
out our different cases so this is quite
like a switch statement in
Java and c-sharp and those sorts of
things so we're going to type is login
event dot on start so we're basically
just going to make a function for each
of these objects here and the data class
as well and then we do an arrow sign
thingy and then what we're gonna do is
we're going to type yet user so we'll
need to code this function out and what
I'd like to do first is I'm just going
to hit alt enter again create function
get user and then we'll just finish off
this particular handle event function
before we get to that so we have two
other cases so again I'm just going to
hit control D just speed things up a
little bit this one's going to be on/off
button click and in that case we're
going to type on/off button click and
again click on that hit pulse enter
create function cool and then for our
last event here we have on Google
sign-in result so in this particular
case we're going to type in the on
sign-in result and then how do we
actually get data out of our sealed
class here so what we can do in this
particular case is we type on sign and
result and then by saying this is Clause
here this actually will cast our event
to the on Google sign-in result if it
does happen to be that particular class
how we get our data out of that is we
say event dot result which returns our
login result object here okay and that's
the property right there and then again
we'll just hit alt enter create function
now this is the function that we're not
going to be coding out today so I'll
just make a note here not coding this
one today but in a later video where we
talk about firebase and co-routines and
stuff like that all right so that is our
handle event function and then what
we'll do next is let's go ahead and get
started with our get user function here
so for get user we are going to be
talking to the repository object up here
Rep oh and let me just open that up
really quickly
I know repository sorry this is AI user
repository and just notice that these
things basically they're all suspend
functions so we're getting into
co-routines land so in order to actually
call these suspend functions we need to
basically use some kind of co-routine
builder generally speaking in this
particular case since we have configured
our base view model to be our root
co-routine scope and our user view model
extends that and i do recommend this i
do recommend this approach for
co-routines
we need to basically make this function
into a launch builder so what we're
going to do is we're going to type
equals launch like so now it's important
to note if you do not configure the
appropriate co-routine scope just notice
that this thing has this this 14 scope
thing right here if you do not configure
that properly things aren't necessarily
going to work the same way you're not
necessarily going to be constrained to
the appropriate coroutine scope and i do
not recommend you use global scope
launch so what we're going to do it's
actually really simple the way I build
applications or we're just going to take
Val result which is going to be we won't
specify the type here we're going to say
Val result equals repo get current user
like so so if you're wondering what the
type is here we're returning this result
wrapper so this is a result wrapper that
I've written myself there's a couple
different libraries and stuff like that
you can use I'll just open it up really
quickly result and it just basically
represents a value so like a success
case and then it represents an error so
like an error case big surprise there
and then the way that we actually use it
is with this handy build function so
anyways that's what we're going to be
returning but more specifically it's
going to return either an exception or a
nullable user object so why does it have
both exception and then a nullable user
well the reason for this is that
we might end up checking our firebase
off for the current user and there's no
current user so in that case we would
return null this isn't necessarily an
error case maybe the user just hasn't
logged in yet so I'm trying to be a
little bit more specific if there's an
actual error occurring then I want that
to basically be a different path that
the event stream takes so anyways what
we're gonna do is we're gonna hop back
to user view model so how I like to use
these result wrappers is again we're
going to use a win/win matcher
so when result is oops not poet's result
dot value like so then in that
particular case we have a block going on
here so there's a couple things we need
to do here if we actually get a user
object from our repple the first thing
we want to do whether it's null or not
is we want to say user state dot value
so this is the value of our user state
object here and this is how mutable live
data mutable live data works so we can
say user state not value equals result
dot value so what we're doing is we're
taking the value out of a result
obviously in then we're just assigning
it to our mutable live data object so
that fixes up our the the state of the
view model here but of course we're
still going to need to update everything
else appropriately so in particular we
need to update our UI binding so how
we're going to do that is we're going to
basically represent the user interface
with a couple of different finite sort
of states so what we'll do is we're
gonna write out all of those one after
another I'm just gonna actually stub
them out first off so what we're gonna
do is we're gonna hit enter again so the
first thing I want to know is is this
thing a null value which again isn't
necessarily an error case
and if it's a null value that means the
user is currently signed out so we're
going to type show signed out state like
so and then we're just again going to
hit alt enter stub that function out and
then we'll add an else case so we're
gonna say else show signed in state
there we go
just stub that bad boy out awesome so
the only other thing we need to do here
is we need to handle our error case so
we're gonna say is result dot error if
that's the case then we want to show
error State cool all right there we go
and as you can see here we have all of
our different UI state functions coded
out okay so we're still not ready to
implement these particular functions yet
what we'll do first is we'll implement
our on/off button click function so
basically what this is going to look
like is we're going to type if user
state dot value which is our live
mutable live data object equals equals
null which means that the user is not
logged in then we want to call off
attempt dot value equals unit so what
that's going to do is it's going to
trigger the auth attempt observable in
our login view here what that's going to
do is that's going to call the start
sign and flow function down below here
and this basically prepares the
application to open up basically a new
sort of activity using on activity
result and what's going to happen is the
user can basically choose to sign in
with their Google account and then once
that process is ready then that result
will be propagated to on activity result
when the activity returns so anyways
going back to the view model that's what
we're going to trigger here so if the
user state value is null the user is
currently logged out
and they have pressed this particular
button here except it would say sign in
for example and that starts our sign-in
process now if the users else if the
user value is not null then that means
the user is currently logged in and they
want to basically log out so in that
case we're gonna call sign out user and
let's just code that function out so
once again in order to actually sign the
user out we need to talk to the
repository object which means once again
we're going to be dealing with our
suspend functions so we can go ahead and
make that into a launch coroutine
builder like so just get rid of that
there and so what this thing is going to
look like is very similar to get user
we're gonna take valve result equals
repo dot sign out current user and then
we're going to use our win matcher so
when result is his result dot value do
something so in this particular case
what we're gonna do is we're going to
type user state dot value equals null so
in this case we're not actually
returning a value we just want to know
if the user was successfully signed out
or not if they were successfully signed
out then we just want to make sure that
the view model reflects that so we type
user state value equals null and then
we're gonna again call our show signed
out state function cool
then we'll handle our error case is
result dot error and then again we're
just gonna call show error state as you
can see there so that's it for the
different control logic functions that
we're going to be coding out today there
is of course the on Google sign-in
result but as I said several times we're
going to cover that in a different video
the last thing we need to do is we need
to actually code out our different
states here so I'm actually going to
select all of this hit control X and I'm
going to bring it up top to just below
our view model objects here
and then we get started all right it's
time to code out our presentation logic
functions now before we do that I just
want to show you really quickly I have
this file in the common package called
constants KT so what we have here are a
whole bunch of Const Val references so
these are compiled time constants which
means that they're very efficient now if
you need to localize your application
for different localizations then
probably you would want to go with
strings.xml in this particular case this
is me just being super lazy and
efficient and just typing out different
strings which ultimately will be
rendered on our UI here just in an
easily accessible file so what we'll do
is instead of sort of hard coding these
different values we're gonna refer to
each appropriate constant and that all
just as you'll see in a moment make our
presentation logic a little bit easier
to write and a little bit harder to
screw up so the first thing we'll do is
we'll work with our error state here so
in this particular case we're gonna say
sign oops sign in status text dot value
so again we're updating the value of our
live day object so the first one's going
to be login error and then the next one
so pretty much how this is going to work
is I'm just going to hit ctrl D twice
and we're going to update these values
so this one's going to be off button
text dot value and so when there's an
error we want the user to be able to
sign in again so that one's going to be
sign in and then for the next one we
have the satellite drawable which is
like the animation right here so if
there's an error then we want to
basically show antennae empty so that's
a URL to a particular drawable it's
actually this one here the empty antenna
animation here alright so once we have
that figure it out and let me just
double check to make sure I didn't screw
anything up that looks okay good enough
for now good to know anyways so I'm
gonna hit ctrl C and I'm just going to
paste this into each of these functions
since this won't change too
much again this is the kind of work that
you really need to test because when
you're doing this kind of copy-paste
crap you almost always screw something
up alright so show signed in state is
what we'll be working with next so when
the user is signed in we want the
sign-in status to say signed in we want
our auth button to basically say sign
out and then for our in antenna drawable
we wanted to say antenna full which is
basically this trouble here except with
the wavy things on top just deploy the
application if you want to see what it
looks like okay so we've got our state
here so show signed in state signed in
sign out antenna full that's looking
good next we'll go to show signed out
state so it's basically going to mirror
this one here so for show signed out
state we're going to say signed out up
here and this one is going to say show
signed end state so this one's going to
say sign in that's correct and then this
one's going to be antenna empty that's
actually correct it's quite simpler to
our error state as you can see alright
so for show loading state it's actually
going to be much simpler so we're just
going to type sign in status text and
we're going to set that one to loading
oops
kind of need an equal sign in there okay
and then all we're gonna do is we're
gonna call our start animation function
here value equals unit so earlier on you
may have noticed in the view if you
watched it previously what we ended up
doing is we actually set the animation
drawable in the view so the reason why
we're doing that and not actually
updating the particular drawable in this
case is if we hop in a login view notice
that I actually specified explicitly
that before we animate our draw it must
be assigned to our antenna loop drawable
so the reason for this is that antenna
loop is actually like the only drawable
which is actually an animation list and
I don't want to have a situation where
I'm say for example assigning just a
regular SVG drawable and then somehow
accidentally I forgot to change that to
the actual animation drawable and then
we are starting an animation drawable
which isn't actually an animation
drawable so basically what we're saying
here is this is a little place where I
actually did include a little bit of
presentation logic in the view but this
is for the sake of avoiding problems
with shared mutable state
so the very first tutorial I ever made
at least on the topic of Android on
YouTube was for the recyclerview way
back in 2016 now back then there was a
couple things about it which made it
kind of tricky to set up for people so
that's kind of what inspired me to try
and make a video on it well I'll be
basically teaching the same API today
but luckily there are a couple of
improvements to it which will allow us
to do a couple of things
so for sirs the recyclerview we'll be
building today is going to be the
adapter at least is going to be
decoupled from the fragment which is
kind of important it's going to handle
click events super easily as we'll see
we don't have to have like seven
different interfaces going on will
actually handle click events just by
using a mutable live data object and
then finally our recycler view that
we're going to build here we're going to
use a particular class called list
adapter which is like kind of a
specialized adapter and what it's going
to allow us to do is it'll basically
remove our need to have to call
functions like notify data set changed
notify ID arrange change notify item
inserted there's basically if you're not
familiar in earlier recyclerview API
implementations you had to call all
these different methods on the adapter
based on what happened in your recycler
view and it could actually get pretty
annoying and complicated so what we'll
do is we'll basically set up a bit of a
boilerplate class called a diff util and
dot item callback I believe it's called
we'll see it in a minute but basically
what this thing's going to allow us to
do is it'll basically remove the need to
call all those different functions and
instead we'll just be calling one
function and then we'll let this diff
util our list adapter and a couple other
things which we'll go into in the video
handle all of those updates for us so
it's going to be way simpler and best of
all this particular implementation is
going to figure out the or calculate the
changes that need to be made to the
recyclerview
on a background thread so no more
blocking the main thread now since this
is tutorial number eight and I've
already covered a whole bunch of topics
such as
writing a view model writing a fragment
model view viewmodel architecture in
general constraint layout all those
different things what we're going to do
is there are certain parts of this
tutorial that we're not going to go into
much detail and however I will show you
all of the different steps necessary to
actually set up the recyclerview what we
won't be doing is we won't code out the
whole fragment which displays the
recyclerview and for the layouts that
we'll be using in the recyclerview i'll
show them to you and mention anything
that's important but we're not going to
build them on camera if you want to
learn how to do that I have a whole
tutorial on constraint layout which will
help you figure that kind of thing out
now before you proceed if you want to
actually follow along with the tutorial
in real time you're going to watch
either clone or download the repository
link in the description box down below
now this could end up being a fairly
long video so I'll make sure I include
timestamps in the description box down
below if you want a detailed idea of the
topics and when we cover them in this
video the first file that we'll be
looking at is called fragment note list
so this is the layout which actually
contains the recyclerview so as I say
I'm not going to go into too much detail
here but here's a preview of the layout
you can't actually see the recyclerview
here but this is basically what it would
look like if there are no items in the
recycler view so I'm just going to open
up the text editor here and we'll just
look at this particular XML view so the
first thing I want to bring your
attention to is we have this color
transparent black background so what I
wanted to do here is instead of just
setting the Alpha of the which alpha
means opacity or the degree to which
something is transparent instead of just
setting that directly on the
recyclerview and kind of blurring things
I just wanted to make sure that the
background of the recyclerview
basically made the elements in it a
little more viewable a little more
visible but you could still see the
space background behind it so the way
that I achieved that effect is I
basically just set the background of the
recyclerview to color transparent black
and if I open up colors XML that's
basically just the color black with a
hex value of 52 for the opacity so in
the sense this is like setting the
except only for the background image so
the second thing to point out here is
that I've specified a linear layout
manager in the XML so I used to do this
in the Java or Kotlin code but actually
find it simpler to just do it
declaratively in the XML in this
particular case and notice that I'm
using a linear layout manager depending
on what kind of layout manager you use
that will kind of dictate how your
recyclerview behaves and how it kind of
arranges the different items within it
final thing to note here is that I've
specified the default visibility of this
particular view to be invisible and as I
explained before that's because when
there's no items retrieved from the
database then I basically just want the
recycler view to be entirely invisible
alright so the next file we'll be
looking at is item note XML so again I'm
just going to talk about some general
things but we're not going to actually
code this particular view out so the
first thing I wanted to mention is that
both the primary graphic and the little
icon down here are vector drawable
resources so I have a tutorial on that
and you can go and watch video number
three in this series if you're curious
about how to set these up but just to
explain really quickly how they work
basically they will scale to pretty much
any screen size within reason and they
won't lose quality or anything like that
and the best part about that is that all
of that happens through one single
drawable resource so we don't need to
specify resources for different screen
sizes with vector drawables now looking
at some of the more specific details
here I just want you to note a couple of
things so the way that I arrived at the
general dimensions margins padding and
those sorts of things is I basically
went to the material design guidelines
website and pretty much copied what they
did now I do align things a little bit
differently than what they suggest and
so what I recommend is if you want to
figure out how to align these things
appropriately go check out what their
guidelines are start from there and then
tweak things a little bit in order to
get the effect that you prefer so
there's one last thing that I want to
mention about this file if I scroll down
to our primary text view here I just
want you to notice that I've specified a
single line equal to true and then I've
specified ellipse size dot and so what
exactly is a lip size dot n this is kind
of important if the text in your
recyclerview may end up being longer
than the screen what a lip size means is
it's just whenever the text kind of cuts
off it's just going to add a dot dot dot
or ellipses as they're known and that's
just going to make our recyclerview look
a little bit prettier in the event that
the text is too long for the screen okay
so we will end up coding the adapter by
hand but there's one little boilerplate
class here which is necessary to write
before our list adapter and basically
what it is is it's a DIF you till dot
item callback object so don't let all
these scary names confuse you all this
little class here does is it basically
takes in some kind of datum model so let
me open up note so note is basically the
conceptual data which each item in our
recycler view will represent so whatever
data model you're trying to display so
it could be like a user it could be an
exercise it could be a note for example
you're basically going to want to create
a DIF util dot item callback object
which basically includes that particular
data model as a generic type here so
what is that going to do all it's going
to do is it's going to allow you to have
some way if your data models have a
unique identifier which they probably
should of figuring out if an item at a
given position has changed or not so if
that's not super clear I think once I
dive into the source code of the list
adapter you'll probably understand how
it kind of works all you need to
understand here is that if you want to
set this thing up properly whatever data
model you have needs to have some kind
of unique identifier in this case I've
chosen the creation date of when the
user
basically creates the new note to be its
unique identifier and then at some point
as we'll see you later on some internal
class is basically going to use our
callback object here in order to
determine what items in the new list are
different from the old list type of
thing okay so in a moment we're actually
going to basically delete this entire
class and then rebuild it this is our
adapter for our recycler view but before
we do that I want to take you through a
bit of the source code of the list
adapter class so as we'll see in a
moment this thing is actually a subclass
of recyclerview dot adapter but it's
integrated with a note or not a note in
particular but some kind of diff util
dot item callback and so as we'll see in
a moment we that's why we needed to
create that particular thing first and
what I'd like to do is I'll take you
through some of the internals of this
class so that you can actually
understand what's going on here so what
I'm going to do now is I'm going to hit
ctrl an and then I'm going to delete
that because that's totally in my way
and what I'm going to type is list
adapter now up in this checkbox here you
can see we have this include non project
items so I'm going to click that and I
want you to notice that all of a sudden
we have a whole bunch of different
options that have popped up so the one
we're actually going to look at from the
library the recycler view library is
list adapter here okay so what's going
on here so all the sudden were in Javel
and because this is a Java class but
what I'll do is I'll just gonna explain
what's going on here so the first thing
I want to point out here is that this
list adapter class as I said before
extends recyclerview dot adapter so it's
capable of behaving as a recycler view
adapter now the most important thing you
need to understand with this particular
class is that it has this async list
differ member here called M differ
now there's two constructors we can use
to create one of these list adapters and
the one we use accepts our diff util dot
item callback object that's important
because it's going to basically
create a new em differ member partly out
of the callback that we supply so in a
moment we'll actually see how this diff
callback actually saves us time and
effort but there's a couple other things
in this class that I wanted to point out
so as I mentioned before how we used to
have to deal with our recyclerview
adapter when the underlying data set
that it's looking at changed is we had
to call all these different functions
like notify item inserted notify item
range removed and all kinds of things
like that so this was really annoying
and caused a lot of problems for
different developers and also the thing
about using notify data set changed is
that it was a very inefficient function
so anyways what we're gonna do is as
we'll see in a moment this list adapter
when we want to actually update the
contents of the adapter all we have to
do is we just call this submit list
function down here and we provide a list
which contains whatever data model that
we're working with so what I want to
point out here is that when this
function is called it's going to call
the same function on our M differ object
and then it's going to pass the list in
what we'll do next is we'll look at the
async list differ source and then we'll
kind of see what goes on inside of there
okay so there's one more source class
that we're gonna look at and understand
I'm just trying to give you an idea of
how this thing works under the hood so
I'm gonna hit ctrl + twice and then
we're gonna look up a sync list differ
here so this is a pretty complicated
class all I want you to want you to
understand here is that this async list
differ class has a main thread executors
object here and what that's going to do
is it's going to allow it to call back
to the main thread and then we'll see it
also is capable of doing work on a
background thread this is important
because if you're making a huge update
to a recycler view that could
potentially be a long-running operation
so this is part of the magic of using
this particular set up with list adapter
and async list differ is that it's going
to allow us to figure these updates out
on the background thread appropriately
and you don't actually even need to know
what's going on here I'm basically just
taking you through the
source code is an extra step so we have
our main thread executor and the only
other thing I want to show you in this
particular object here is I want to
scroll down to the submit list function
and just remember submit list is what
we're calling on our list adapter and
then that's going to get called on our M
differ member okay so if we go down to
submit list here we'll see the first
function here accepts a list and then
the next one is basically going to call
the it's going to call an overloaded
version of this function down here
Submit list and this is actually where
the magic happens now the thing you I
just want to point out to you is if I
scroll down I know this is a really
horrendously huge function here but if I
scroll down here just understand at a
certain point we're going to say M
config don't worry about what that it is
it's basically going to get a background
thread executors and this is how it's
going to actually calculate the
difference between the old list and the
new list and do that work on the
background thread for us now importantly
one little detail if you're wondering
how it actually gets ahold of the note
diff util callback that we created
understand that it's going to get a hook
to that class through this M config
object here which we actually created up
in the list adapter somewhere here and
we have a little builder class there and
so it's going to get a hook to the diff
util callback that you wrote and then
from there it's going to ask it to
compare the different items and that's
ultimately why we needed to create our
diff util callback once all of this is
done it's going to dispatch this result
to the main thread okay so now that
we've had a look at the internals of the
list adapter class that we'll be working
with and hopefully that was interesting
to you if you enjoyed going through the
source code then please let me know down
in the description box below and I'll
try and do that kind of thing in the
future so anyways at this point we're
gonna rebuild our note list adapter
class and what we're gonna do is just go
ahead and open it up and we're just
gonna select everything in here except
the import statement at the top
and we're just gonna delete it like so
alright so you might be wondering at
this point Ryan how exactly is that
making things easier for us that seems
kind of complicated well the good news
is that the complexity in the classes
that we just went through is going to
result in less complexity in the classes
that we're going to be writing
momentarily so in order to actually
write out our adapters constructor we
need to create our view holder object
first so we'll start with that
so this class is going to be called
class note oops
can type note view of holder it's going
to have one property here which is going
to be called route and it's going to be
of type view and we'll see what happens
in a moment with that and then it's
going to have it's going to extend
recyclerview oops that's not what I
wanted recycler view dot view holder
like so and what we'll do is it's going
to complain because it's expecting this
thing to accept a view so that's where
we'll pass in this route view object
here and so that will become the item
view property of the view holder and
just take note of that because we'll use
it later on so the purpose of this class
is it's basically kind of like a bridge
between our note data model or whatever
data model you'll be using and our item
note layout so it's kind of like a
virtual representation of the layout and
so in our particular layout we really
only need to represent the in this case
the creation date and also the contents
of the note in the actual layout so it
follows that we just need to include two
different references here so the first
one is going to be called VAR content
for the contents of the note it's going
to be a textview and it's going to equal
root dot LBL message so again don't
forget root is referring to this thing
here and then I'm just going to select
at the click at the end of here and I'm
going to hit ctrl D and this next one is
also a textview it's going to be called
date and it's going to point to root dot
LBL date and time so just a really
aside here about the note viewholder if
you're wondering where the name
recyclerview actually comes from or what
it refers to it basically means that as
the user is scrolling through their list
of items in the recyclerview the
recyclerview adapter is going to recycle
the view holder objects instead of
creating a view holder object for every
item in the recycler view so minor point
here but it's just kind of important to
understand that that's where we actually
get the efficiency of the recycler view
and why it's called as such okay so now
that we've got our view holder set up we
can actually write the class declaration
for our adapter so what that's going to
look like is we're gonna type class note
list adapter I'm gonna leave the
constructor empty for a moment but we
will put something in there and then
this this class here is going to extend
list adapter and it's going to basically
accept a couple of different types here
so what we need to do here is if you
want to figure out what this particular
what a given class needs in Android
studio for constructors or types like
this generic types we can hit ctrl P and
it's actually going to kind of give us
some kind of idea so in the case of T
this actually refers to our data model
so in this case I'm going to type note
and then for the second one we have some
kind of view holder object and that's
going to end up being our note view
holder and that's why we needed to
create that thing first so in here I'm
going to type note list adapter dot note
view holder now it's still complaining
because as you can see here we're
referring to something which is supposed
to be within note list adapter so I'm
just going to throw down some curly
brackets here and then we're gonna move
that note view holder object into the
adapter like so so there's obviously a
couple things we need to fix here so go
ahead and click on the red highlighted
note list adapter here and what I'm
going to do is I'm going to hit alt
enter and then we can click on implement
members or hit enter and make sure you
select both of these and then hit OK
and so these are the functions that you
basically need to implement and in order
for this thing to work properly notice
how there's a couple fewer functions
then compared to a normal recyclerview
adapter and that's because some of those
functions are actually handled inside
this list adapter class so we'll get to
implementing those in a moment there's
another thing we need to deal with so
our list adapter is showing up red and
if I click inside the parentheses here
and hit ctrl P it's going to say that
it's expecting some kind of diff util
dot item callback object so all we need
to do in this case is I'm just going to
type note DIF util callback and then
we'll add brackets at the end of it and
that's going to actually create an
instance of the node if you tale
callback object so in my older tutorials
the way that I handled click events was
basically to either nest the adapter
inside of the fragment or activity which
it was supposed to call back to or by
holding reference to whatever class it
was trying to call back to as an
interface so we're gonna do neither of
those and take an option which is a
little bit more decoupled and I think a
little bit safer so what we're gonna do
instead is we're going to use a mutable
live data object to call back to the
fragment so what we'll do is we're gonna
type Val event and it's going to be of
type mutable live data and the type is
going to be a sealed class which is note
list event so if you're wondering
exactly what this is
and how a mutable live data work go and
check out the particular part of the
tutorial where I actually discuss these
topics just really really quickly note
list event is a sealed class which
represents different events which can
occur in the front end and mutable live
data is basically something that can be
observed but this mutable word means
that we can change its value and the
value is what's basically wrapped up
here whenever we want to and when we
change it if our fragment for example
happens to be listening to this mutable
live data object then it will know
a particular event happens and what the
details are so in order to complete this
we're just going to have to actually
create this thing so we'll say equals
mutable live data and we'll give it our
constructor so the first function that
we'll implement is oncreateview holder
so beyond what the name implies here
basically what this particular function
does is this is where we actually
inflate the layout which our recycler
view will use so what we're going to do
is we're just going to mess around a
little bit here so we're gonna say Val
inflator equals layout inflator dot from
and so we're gonna use this parent
object here which is a view group so
from parent dot context and that's going
to get ahold of a context object now
this is really important whenever you're
messing with context you need to be
careful about memory leaks and there's a
particular step we're going to go over
in the fragment which is going to
prevent this particular adapter from
leaking this is kind of a problem with
adapters is we have this ugly situation
where it's a class that needs to have
access to things like layout inflaters
and the view hierarchy but it might be
somewhat detached from the lifecycle of
say the fragment so like I say we'll see
a specific step we need to follow in the
fragment in order to make sure that this
isn't an issue for memory leaks anyways
once we have our layout inflator object
what we'll do next is we're gonna type
return note view holder like so and
inside of this note view holder object
which expects a route view this is where
we'll actually do our inflation so we're
gonna say inflator dot inflate and so in
here we're going to provide the actual
item note layout which is the layout of
each item in the recycler view our
layout item note and then we're going to
give it parent which was passed in up
here
and then we're also going to provide
we're gonna say false for attach to root
okay so some of you might be wondering
what exactly is this attached to root
and why is it false if we leave it false
does that mean that our views our view
holders are going to be magically
floating around the user interface and
unbound to anything the reason why we're
passing false in here is because we do
not actually we don't write the code to
attach this particular view to the view
hierarchy so basically what that means
is that it's going to inflate this our
dot IO dot item note view it's going to
get some layout parameters from this
parent object and if I hit ctrl P notice
this thing is called root and so just
understand that everything's going to
work fine when would you want to use
attach to root true that would be if you
are writing some particular class which
is responsible for attaching a view to
the hierarchy in this case this occurs
internally so we can just leave it false
and we don't have to worry about it all
right so what we're gonna do next is
we're gonna write out our unbind view
holder function so the first thing we'll
do is we want to basically get a hold of
the note item at a given position and
position is provided here so what we'll
do is we'll call get item which is a
function from the adapter and then we'll
pass in position then we're gonna say
dot let so basically what's gonna happen
here is we're saying okay get this thing
and then in this block of code as soon
as you get that thing I want to do
something with it
so in this case just to make things a
little bit more legible instead of using
the it reference which is a little bit
confusing to some people I'm just going
to type note so we're gonna give a name
to the thing that is returned by this
function and then it kind of pops up up
in here then we need to add an arrow
thingy here so what we're actually going
to do is once we get our note object
here we need to bind it to the view
holder object which was
Bastin so what we're going to do is
we're going to take holder dot content
for the first one and remember that's
just what we defined down here holder
content dot text because it's a textview
equals note dot contents gonna hit ctrl
D and for this one we're going to say
holder dot date dot text equals note
creation date and then what we'll do
after that is we're going to add a click
listener to the entire sort of route
layout of the view holder object so
we're gonna say holder dot item view dot
set on click listener and we're just
going to use a lambda in this case again
so what's gonna happen is when this on
click listener is fired whatever we
write in here is going to be executed
and so what we're going to do in that
case is we're going to publish an event
to anything which is listening and the
way we're going to do that is we're
going to use our event mutable live data
property up here so what we want to do
there is we're going to type event dot
value to get the value of the mutable
live data object then we're going to set
that value to a particular kind of event
in this case the event will be note list
event dot on note item click and then
that thing requires a position which
will be the position that is passed in
in on bind view holder now I'm sure some
of you are wondering what this class
looks like so I'll pull it up really
quickly so note list event and just
understand it has a couple different
events basically any event which can
occur in the note list feature of the
application and the one we used is on
note item click and as you can see here
it accepts a position as a property
which is what we pass into it so that's
actually it for our adapter object so
what we'll do to finish this video off
is I'll take you through the fragment
which holds the recycler view and
interacts with the adapter now we're not
going to code everything out because
that would take a needlessly long time
and of our
explain how to code up fragments in a
previous video but what I will do is
take you through specific steps which
you probably should take to avoid things
like memory leaks and to make sure that
everything gets set up properly
ok so I've opened up note list view now
as you can see here we have a reference
to the adapter in the fragment I do
recommend taking that route and not
putting a reference to the adapter in
something like a view model the reason
why is that you don't really want to be
put in classes which have a reference to
like layout inflator and context and the
view hierarchy in something like view
model so in this case like I say we're
talking to it through the fragment here
now this is a really important step here
you can see I've overridden ondestroy
view in the fragment so what was
happening is that after I got this thing
all set up I was getting a very strange
memory leak and I figured that out by
using the tool leak canary a very
awesome tool so I was trying to figure
out what was going on here and after a
bit of googling I figured out that in
certain cases and again this is just the
feature a feature of the fact that our
adapter is tightly coupled to the view
hierarchy and context and layout
inflator and all that stuff if you do
not set the adapter property of the
recycler view and that's what this thing
is here to null then chances are you may
get a memory leak I think it partly
depends on how you have everything set
up here but in this particular case if
we want to have our adapter sort of
separate from the fragment I did need to
include this detail here otherwise I got
a memory leak now some of you may be
wondering and I went over this in the
fragment tutorial in this series but the
way that we're able to just directly
refer to these XML views like so is by
using Kotlin synthetic properties up
here so go check the fragment tutorial
out if you want an idea of how to do
that it basically completely eliminates
fine view by ID which is really handy
anyways the only function well there's
two functions we're gonna look at next
so one of them is going to be setup
adapter here
and so this is just a helper function
that I've created so that we don't have
just one giant on start function and
when I scroll down to it this is what we
have here so what we end up doing is we
create a new instance of our note list
adapter and we assign it to our adapter
reference the next thing that we do is
we get a hook to the event property
remember that's our mutable live data
object and then we observe it so that
when a click event happens in the
adapter in the recycler view it's going
to pop up here now since our fragment
has referenced the view model as well
what we'll do is through this lambda
function here that's where we will pass
the particular event and remember that
contains the position of the item that
was clicked we passed that into the view
model and then let the view model figure
out what to do from there now the last
thing that we do after we get that set
up is we assign our recycler view its
property its adapter property to the
adapter we just created and now for the
moment you've all been waiting for how
do we actually get our data into this
particular recycler view adapter and
recycler view so if I scroll down to the
observe view model function and just
note that I'm calling that after I set
the adapter up so just for people
watching this make sure you kind of
don't mix these steps up here we're
setting it up first and then we're
asking the view model for the data so if
I scroll down to the particular
observable which is note list so that's
of course our list of notes we observe
it and then when we receive a new note
list all we have to call is adapter dot
submit list now don't worry about this
function here this is just like UI
animation boilerplate stuff this is
seriously all we need to do to provide a
new list to our adapter and anytime we
change the underlying list it's going to
pop up in here we're gonna call adapter
dot submit list the diff util is going
to figure out what to do from there and
then we are set
no more notify data set changed notify
item inserted or confusion with
creating a new list of data or all those
kinds of things because for anyone who
worked with recyclerview before it was
actually kind of difficult and confusing
how to like for example update an entire
list or change part of it or things like
that so all of that work that we did
earlier did actually ultimately make our
adapter simpler to work with
and in this video I'm going to talk
about integrating firebase auth and
Google sign-in provider in your Android
applications so in order to set up
firebase authentication with Google
sign-in provider we will need to perform
the following steps will create and
configure firebase for an android
project will set up a sha-1 certificate
in Android studio for debug builds will
download the Google services JSON file
after all the configuration is done
we'll have a quick look at what we need
in our project level and module level
build.gradle files and once that's all
complete we will implement firebase off
and Google sign and provider in a small
little Android application and I will
show you where to get the source in a
moment now before proceeding I will need
you to have an account setup with
firebase so go ahead and do that if you
haven't already so assuming you have an
Android app which you want to connect to
firebase the easiest way to integrate it
in recent versions of Android studio is
to select tools firebase authentication
and then click connect to firebase if
this process worked for you it should
have created a new Android project in
firebase if it doesn't I suggest you
enter the firebase console and create a
new Android based project manually next
click the add firebase authentication to
your app button this will add in some
Gradle dependencies to make things a
little bit easier for you for the next
step we will set up authentication in
firebase go ahead and open up the
firebase console and click on the
authentication page next click sign-in
method in the following tutorial where
we actually implement code for firebase
auth we just use Google sign-in provider
for your first try this you might want
to just stick with email password
authentication before we can do much
else we need to configure a sha-1
certificate for our application this is
just a unique identifier which we will
add to our firebase project's
configuration to get the debug
certificate which Android studio
generates forests simply build your
project at least once open the Gradle
tab in Android studio and try either
project named tasks Android signing
report or if that doesn't show up
try app tasks Android signing report
in the run console locate your sha-1
certificate and copy it back in the
firebase console navigate to settings
towards the bottom of the general tab
you should see a card which holds your
app ID and allows you to download your
Google services JSON file on that card
click add fingerprint and paste in the
debug certificate now there's something
very important I need to mention I'm
going to show you how to set this up
using a debug sha-1 certificate which
Android studio automatically creates for
you so this will allow you to test debug
versions of your application but just
understand that when you upload your
application to Google Play if you sign
that application with a different shot
one certificate which you really should
do then you're going to need to add that
certificate back into firebase as well
and also if you're like me and you use
app signing by Google Play you're going
to want to go into the Play console open
release management and then app signing
and you're going to want to paste the
public sha-1 certificate fingerprint in
the console into firebase as well now
that we have our certificate set up it's
time to download our Google services
JSON file this file contains keys and
configurations which will allow our
client app to work with firebase in
Google sign-in now if you downloaded
this file before adding your Charlotte
certificate you will need to download it
again alright now that we have all that
configuration done it's time to see how
we actually implement firebase off and
Google sign in provider in the
application this will require properly
configuring Gradle implementing start
sign-in flow and on activity result
which are functions in the front end and
implementing firebase auth in the back
end of the application now I will only
be writing out a couple functions in an
entire application so please check the
description box for the source code for
the entire application I also build this
application out in many different
segments in this whole tutorial series
so consider checking out the other
videos if you want to know how I set up
the view model the rest of the view and
things like that before proceeding
please double check that in your project
level build.gradle file you have the
Google repository present in the all
project script within the build script
and also that you have a dependency to
Google services in the build script as
well in your
module-level build.gradle file you want
to have at least firebase core firebase
off and play services off if you wish to
use google sign it in this up i chose to
build a custom login UI and if you want
to learn how to do that please watch
part 4 of this tutorial series where I
demonstrate how to build a custom
material design log in UI using
constraint layout
alright we need to write a couple of
functions in the view so the first one
is start sign-in flow start sign and
flow will start an external activity
which will display the Google sign-in
user interface this will briefly pause
our application and open up an external
application
now important point here are dot string
dot default web client ID is not
something that you actually write
yourself and add to your strings.xml
file this is something which is
generated dynamically from your Google
services JSON file in older versions of
Google sign-in and firebase you did have
to add this in yourself but at this
point there's just less configuration
you have to do for Google sign and get
client if you're writing this in an
activity you can just type this since
this particular login view happens to be
a fragment and said we'll just type in
require activity
like I said before we're going to be
actually starting a different
application so that's why we're creating
an intent here and whether or not the
user signs in the result will still get
passed into on activity result once the
user finishes the Google sign and user
interface
a quick point here RC Cynon is just some
unique integer key let me just show you
it really quick yeah it's literally just
leet so RC sign in which stands for
requestcode sign in' is going to get
passed into on activity result if you
are working in an application which uses
on activity result for a couple
different things then you're going to
want to actually check to see if RC sign
in equals leet in this case in this
application we're only working with
Google sign in so I don't expect it to
be called in any other case
so basically what we're writing here is
this is just a bunch of boilerplate code
to see if the user signed in properly
and also to see if we were able to get a
user token from their Google account
what will happen is if we successfully
get a user token we will end up passing
that to the back end of the application
and that's how we'll kind of connect
both Google sign-in and also firebase
together oh yeah this is pretty typical
boilerplate code now Google sign-in gets
signed in account from intent returns a
task object and our task object can
throw an exception so we'll just need to
make sure that we're handling that
somehow since this is a demo application
we'll just print it out to the console
the last thing we'll do is we'll
actually inform the view model that on
activity result has been called
hearing using a sealed clasp to kind of
model that particular UI event and I'm
also creating this login result object
let me show you what login result looks
like it's actually just a simple data
class as you can see it holds the
request code and the user token which
could be null all right now that our
view is wired up the next thing we'll
write is our implementation of firebase
off and Google sign and provider in the
backend now there are a couple different
ways to write this code depending on
what tools you use for concurrency since
this is a Kotlin app and I want the
backend to be very decoupled from the
front-end we will manage concurrency and
callbacks using co-routines
so our first function here is called
sign in Google user this function takes
in the ID token we collected when the
user successfully signs in with their
Google account this function is used to
create a new user and to log in a user
which already exists assuming they're
using Google sign-in as I explained in
my Kotlin course an easy way to move a
long-running operation into a background
thread in a suspend function is to use
the width context
dispatchers i/o co-routine builder to
wrap the function body
my general goal of co-routines is to
write code in direct style which is
basically a word for no callbacks this
makes code more legible and helps to
avoid callback health so the first thing
we'll do is we will request a credential
from Google auth provider then we're
going to try and give that credential to
firebase off
so firebase off not signing with
credential returns a task object which
we can add a non complete listener to in
order to keep my goal of writing code in
direct style we will create an extension
function which will wrap the callbacks
using the suspend Co routine builder so
we're not actually going to write it out
but I'll just walk you through it really
quickly so we're going to be using a
weight task complete about what that
basically means is we're going to await
the task and we want to know if it
completes or not but we don't actually
care about returning any particular
value in order to create this function
we simply take in a task as a parameter
and then we use the suspend Co routine
builder so the way that this works is
the continuation object is how we
actually call back to the call site of
the function which will be using our
extension function here so what we do is
we just add a non complete listener to
our task object and we check to see if
it's successful or not if it's
successful we just resume the execution
of the call sight function now I'm
returning unit year because it doesn't
actually matter what value I return and
if it fails we call resume with
exception let's see how that works back
at the call site so what we'll do is
we'll add a try-catch block to wrap that
particular function call
now if it just resumes then like I said
before it will just synchronously jump
to the next line after a weight task
completed in this case we will create a
result wrapper result dot build to
signify that we just want to return the
function successfully if we get an
exception we will catch that exception
and throw it also in our result wrapper
all right so we only have two other
functions to write out here so signing a
user out is very easy at least in this
particular application all I do is I
just call off dot sign out now what I'll
do is I'll just add that particular call
into a result wrapper if it succeeds it
will return unit which is basically a
signal that things happen successfully
but we don't care about any particular
return value next we have get current
user when the user opens the login
screen the first thing the app does is
request the current user from this
particular back-end function now it's
important to understand that I've
initialized firebase ahead of time in
this class by calling firebase off get
instance generally speaking you will
want to initialize firebase ahead of
time instead of calling it just before
you call for example I thought current
user and the reason for that is if you
call off current user before firebase is
properly initialized then it will
basically just return null to you no
matter what happens that's even if the
user is actually signed in
so if off dot user does equal null then
we will actually just return null in the
result wrapper
otherwise we will return a user object
now again this is basically just a plain
domain model which will hold on to the
UID and the display name of a user if
they happen to have one now the truth
here is that I don't actually use the
UID or the display name for anything so
I could actually just return unit here
as well and that would function
perfectly fine for this application so
that's all you need to setup firebase
auth and Google sign-in provider
in this video I'm going to show you how
to put together a room database using
Kotlin co-routines here's a quick
overview of what we'll be doing in this
tutorial first we will build a room
entity which is kind of like a bridge
between SQL and Kotlin or Java then we
will build a data access object
interface which is how we will actually
get the data in and out of our room
database then we will look at our room
database class and a bit of information
on threading and concurrency and finally
we will see how to perform crud
operations on the database using Co
routines
crud operations stands for create read
update and delete just a quick reminder
that as usual the source code for this
example will be in the description box
so let's get started entities in room
are essentially a bridge between a Java
or in this case Kotlin data model and
the schema of an SQL database in simpler
terms an SQL database is basically a
spreadsheet and each property of our
entity will represent a cell in that
spreadsheet so to setup an entity in
room what you want to do is you want to
start with a basic data model like I
have here so what we'll need to do to
set up this data model for room is we'll
need to add a bunch of annotations to it
above the class declaration you will
want to add the entity annotation this
annotation accepts quite a few different
arguments depending on what kind of
configurations you want or you can leave
it blank for defaults this annotation
accepts quite a few different arguments
depending on what configurations you
want or you can leave it blank and it
will just use the defaults table name
and indices shown in blue here are what
are known as Kotlin default arguments
table name basically states that I want
the name of the database table to quite
specifically be notes if you were to
leave that blank then room would simply
use the name of your entity class by
default as for indices here I'm
basically saying that I want this
particular value creation date to be
indexed and watch we see where that
comes from in a moment but what the
indexing does is it basically just makes
it more efficient to look up these
particular room note objects by this
particular value creation date every
room entity needs to have at least one
primary key you can also create a
primarykey out of multiple different
properties using a composite primary key
but we won't worry about that here what
this annotation does is it basically
tells room that this is the actual value
which we want to use to distinguish
between the different objects in our
database in essence we are saying that
this is the unique identifier for each
room note object now in case you're
rendering creation date is actually
created in the front end of the
application and it's essentially just
the system time at which the note object
was created at and then translated into
a legible date format another optional
annotation is the column info annotation
basically what it allows me to do is
specify a different name for each column
in the database and this is really just
convention SQL doesn't typically use
camel case like in Java or Kotlin but
you don't really need to do this if you
don't want to one final note here if
you've read the documentation then
you're probably aware that room can auto
generate and auto increment primary Keys
we don't do that in this particular
tutorial but I just wanted to mention
that that is a possibility
it does have some consequences though
when it comes to updating rows in the
database which I'll talk about later
next we have our data access object or
Dao now essentially what this is is it's
just an interface with a bunch more
annotations which we'll look at in a
moment this del object will allow us to
give our room database a bunch of
functions which we can call on it to
manipulate our data basically what it'll
do once we set up all of the annotations
is it'll handle most of the work of
writing really ugly SQL queries if
that's not something you're interested
in now there's an important point here
many people use live data with room and
that is acceptable since I'm a big fan
of clean architecture I don't actually
like to be passing live data objects
through my domain layer so instead of
using live data objects for concurrency
we are going to be using co-routines
thankfully in recent versions of room it
basically works out of the box all we
need to do is just add the suspend
co-routine keyword and this will
actually make it super easy for us to
get the data in and out of the room
database without blocking the main
threat anyways the first annotation that
we'll need is at the top of the
interface declaration just Pat down for
our first function we will use the query
annotation so basically how this works
is the
other things we put within this query
annotation will be translated into
proper SQL this basically just makes it
so that it's easier for us to read and
write the particular queries this first
statement here select is pretty
self-explanatory but when it's followed
by this asterisk
it basically means select all from is
also quite self-explanatory and just
remembered notes is what I called the
actual database so basically what we're
saying here is get everything from the
note database now when we want to get a
note by ID basically what we're saying
here is select any note from the note
database where the creation date which
is a particular column in the database
matches this creation date string which
we pass in to this function so notice
how in this particular case we have this
colon followed by the name of the
argument that we give to the function
this is how we actually pass that string
data into the SQL statement delete is
much simpler all we do is we just add in
this delete annotation we pass in the
room note object and room will sort out
the rest of the details for insert or
update I'm doing something a little bit
more complicated now remember how I said
earlier that room is capable of
auto-generating IDs dynamically for you
since we are not doing that that's
actually going to allow us to use this
kind of absurd functionality here so how
this basically works is we pass in a
room note object into the room database
and room will search to see if there's
any note which exists in the database
that matches the one we passed in here
if it does happen to find one where the
creation date matches then we are
telling it explicitly using the on
conflict default argument to replace
that particular note object so
effectively what we have here is both an
update and a create new entry in the
database at the same time now this works
because creation date does not change
whenever we update the particular note
object again if you're using dynamically
generated IDs you have to be a little
bit more careful about that before we
move on to writing the database it's
worth mentioning that room will generate
an implementation of our dowel class in
the build folder of your android project
you don't need to look at it but for
those of you who are curious about how
room works under the hood it might be
interesting in particular notice how it
does have a reference to a room database
object and also it does override the
functions in our interface such as
insert or update note delete note and so
forth in the case of get notes as you
can see here it does a lot of tedious
work for us so that is kind of the magic
of room next we come to the room
database class now this class is
basically just a bunch of boilerplate
and I would not advise you to write this
out by hand just copy and paste it and
change what you need in my case I copied
and pasted this originally from Android
sunflower which is from the Google
samples repositories anyways there's
only a few things to mention here notice
how we are referencing our room note
class also if for some reason we changed
the structure of our database schema we
will want to increment the version by
one or something like that and also
notice that we have a function which
returns our node owl object as well see
in a moment we actually create the room
note database object and then we request
this room note now from it and that's
how we'll actually make calls to the
database as for this companion object
it's basically just a really powerful
singleton initializer and it ensures
that we never have more than one
instance of our database in memory for
those curious the volatile annotation
ensures that no matter what thread tries
to access the instance it will always
get a current instance not something
that's cached and therefore out of date
also this synchronized block here is
kind of interesting so this is a lock
which is a concept you'll be familiar
with if you've studied operating systems
basically what this means is that
whenever a thread of the application
enters this particular code block it
essentially locks it off so that no
other threads can access it at the same
time it will go about doing its business
building the database or retrieving it
if necessary and this essentially doubly
ensures that this thing does not get
created more than once
now if you're just here to use a room
database this kind of concurrency stuff
is not really that important to you so
if it didn't make sense don't worry
about it I just thought it was worth
mentioning one final point here just
like our dao you can actually look up
the implementation of your abstract
database class in the build folder if
you want to see how it works the code is
really ugly but i always encourage
people to actually look at the source
code of these things to better learn how
they work so before i show you how we
manipulate the room database i just want
to show you how i actually create it
each feature of this
has it's very own injector which is a
very simple dependency injection in
container written by hand
so how we actually do things here is we
will create an instance of our room
database which requires context but we
don't actually want to pass a reference
to the database itself rather we will
call dot room no doubt to get an
instance to the data access object in
this app I use a repository which
handles both online and offline calls to
different data sources essentially how
this works is we just check to see if
there is an active user if there is an
active user then we will of course
perform our operations on a remote fire
store database if no user exists then we
just write to our local room note
database so this reference local refers
to our Dao so working with the Dao is
super easy
again reusing co-routines so note that
these are suspend functions anyways all
we do is we just call whatever function
we want on the Dao so get local notes we
call local get notes and it's a similar
situation for the other functions we
have here now you may be wondering why
I'm returning unit here in these result
wrappers just note that for the case of
deletes and insert or updates I don't
actually care about returning a
particular value so to satisfy the
signature of these result wrappers I
just returned unit also note that in my
result wrapper if an exception is thrown
it will be gobbled up by the result
wrappers that's basically how I handle
errors at the same time the only other
thing we need to look at here which I've
added as kind of a custom addition is I
have a bunch of extension functions and
properties to map to and from note
objects and room note objects let's have
a quick look at those so in this project
I have a big file called data extensions
Katie and I put in a whole bunch of
different extension functions and
extension properties so this is pretty
typical mapping stuff the reason why I
do this is I don't want all of the
different room dependencies to be
passing through my domain layer so
basically before I write to the database
or retrieve data from the database I
just make sure that I'm mapping to and
from some kind of plain note object as
you can see this is why I choose not to
use live data I want to try and keep
things as clean as possible
and in this video I'm going to show you
how to manage a fire store cloud
database quickly and easily using Kotlin
co-routines before proceeding please
create a new fire based project for
Android let's enable fire store through
Android studio to do this you can go to
tools firebase scroll down to the bottom
of the assistant tab there you'll see
fire store click on that click read and
write documents from cloud fire store
and click add cloud fire store to your
app if necessary click connect your app
to firebase then click add cloud fire
store to your app which will add the
appropriate Gradle dependency to your
build.gradle file next we will hop in to
the firebase console and set up fire
store we'll start it in test mode which
does not have any access restrictions on
reads and writes but obviously you want
to avoid doing that for production
builds once that process is done we're
ready to go fire store is schemas so we
can start adding data without needing to
configure things further as discussed in
a previous tutorial number 10 where we
built a room database this application
uses a repository to hide the details of
the back-end from the front end how it
works
is that we first check firebase off to
see if a user is in in this get active
user function and depending on what that
result is we either make our operations
on the local room database or we perform
operations on the firestore remote
database also note that I have created a
specific data model for fire store notes
the only difference here is that I store
just the user ID in the fire store node
whereas in the other node object it
stores a nested user object this makes
it easy to serialize and deserialize the
data and also keeps references to fire
store out of my repository interface
finally as usual I encourage you to
check out the source code in the
description box as this is an open
source application let's take a look at
the functions we will be implementing
for fire store get remote notes we'll
get all notes by a particular user yet
remote note will get a particular note
by a particular user delete remote note
is pretty self-explanatory and update
remote note will be used to both create
and update notes which already exists
now like I discussed in part 9 of this
tutorial I've created some quick and
easy co-routine extension functions
which wrap the calls to firebase
you can see here please watch the
tutorial for a detailed explanation all
of our calls to fire store and that's
what this remote references here we'll
start with this collection function
which accepts a collection path argument
of type string instead of having rows
and columns which represent different
items in a database fire store has
documents to represent individual items
or models grouped into collections so
while it's important to remember that
fire store is not an SQL database this
collection path is similar to the name
of a table in a database if you happen
to be familiar likewise each document is
in some sense similar to a row or entry
in a database table this app only has
one collection and it's just called
notes as we'll see with all of these
different functions here we start
everything by retrieving a collection
and then we'll add some other functions
to start manipulating it this call to
the document function will either
retrieve or create a reference to a
document based on the path we give it
now in this case the document path is a
combination of the date at which the
note was created down to the second
combined with the UID of the firebase
user this set function which accepts an
arbitrary data model is how we actually
populate our newly created document with
the appropriate data so in other words
what we're basically saying here is grab
a reference to the notes collection
create a document with this particular
key or name or path and set the data at
that path to be equal to the note which
we passed in converted into a firebase
note object in any case all we do is
call this function here and if it
succeeds properly we will return unit
which basically just means hey this
thing was successful and if an error
gets thrown in a weight test completable
then our catch block here will gobble it
up and we'll know that something went
wrong delete is really easy we just do
exactly what we did before except
instead of saying dot set we just called
dot delete the process for retrieving a
specific note is also similar in this
case we call the same thing except in
this case we will call get at the end of
our change document request now this
will return a task object which
possesses a document snapshot so what we
do is we call this two object function
to turn it into a firebase so what we do
is we call this two
jerk function here which accepts some
kind of data model in this case firebase
note which is what I use to upload
originally with and if we can
successfully retrieve that I just turn
it back into a plain old note object and
then it's good to go
forget remote notes which will return
all notes for a given user again we
request a particular collection and then
we use this where equal to function
which accepts the name of the field in
firebase and then we just pass in the
user ID of the currently logged in user
and then we call this get function now
this particular task object will of
course hold a list of document snapshots
so what we end up doing is I pass it
into this function here result to note
list and it just returns everything as a
result wrapper containing a list of
notes that's just a basic mapping
operation going on here
so that's actually all we need to do to
set up firestore it is ready to go and
out of the box it actually works both
online and offline which is pretty handy
in this tutorial I'm going to show you
how to set up dependency injection in a
very simple modular way which does not
require you to use a dependency
injection framework this hand-written
dependency injection implementation or
build logic as I like to call it is
suitable for small to medium scale
applications if you are building a very
large scale application then writing
this code can be very tedious in which
case I do recommend using dagger 2
dependency injection in simple English
really just means giving an object its
dependencies in the application we've
been building our view model classes
talk to repository interfaces to perform
IO operations on the data these
repository interfaces can therefore be
said to be dependencies of the view
model classes again the key difference
here is that if the view model builds
its own dependency as you can see on the
right example here this is not
dependency injection as I have said time
and time again likely the most important
concept in good software design is
separation of concerns dependency
injection is a form of separation of
concerns except that instead of
separating things like user interface
code logic and data we are separating
things which use dependencies from
things which create dependencies as
Martin Fowler summarizes it very well
dependency injection is about separating
configuration from use the way which I
separate objects that build repositories
from the objects which use repositories
in this project is by writing an
injector class for each feature of the
application this class extends Android
view model which is a subclass of view
model designed to hold on to an instance
of the application context the idea is
simple for each dependency that I
require I'll write the code necessary to
build that dependency and provide a
public function which can be called for
another class to get a hold of that
dependency in this case we will be
providing dependencies for a view model
so we actually end up giving the
repository to a view model Factory
object which we'll look at next note
list view model Factory is in some sense
also an application of separating
configure
from use this is the class I give the
repository to and then it in turn gives
that repository and the appropriate
cover teen dispatcher to note ListView
model the only other piece of this
puzzle is the place where we actually
make our calls to our di implementation
which in this case is within the on
start function of a fragment view model
provider which is how we actually get a
hold of our view models accepts a view
model provider Factory object as a
second parameter which I showed you
moments ago so all we do is we create an
instance of the note list injector give
it context so that it can build room and
then invoke its function to return a
factory there are many other approaches
to separating configuration from use
such as using the service locator
pattern which I also use quite
frequently the approach I showed you
today hopefully gave you a way to start
applying dependency injection without
spending weeks configuring dagger 2
we've all been there and yeah it sucks
you